[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
'le champions comme des propriétaires
qui venaient faire l'inspection de leur
nouveau territoire
et si quelqu'un m'avait dit alors que je
passerais ma vie à faire en sorte
qu'israël se retire de tous ces
territoires
j'aurais pris pour un fou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque nuit les arabes nous attaquer ou
nous les attaques ion nous étions sous
le choc
lors d'une audition mais ce n'est pas
possible notre armée ne fait pas des
choses pareilles et ce soldat a confirmé
si l'armée il fait tout ça moi même je
les fais et je ne peux plus en dormir la
nuit
on ne peut pas trouver de maisons
palestiniennes dont un habitant n'a pas
été prisonniers morts ou blessés
ce sont des citoyens de seconde zone
dans leur propre pays
ça a changé ma vie ça m'a frappé nous ne
pourrons pas vivre ensemble sans
détruire ses murs
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités en plateau et nos
reporters sur le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce lundi 24 février premier jour du
procès d'extradition de julian assange
au royaume uni ils risquent 175 ans de
prison aux etats-unis washington qui
accuse le fondateur de wikileaks
aujourd'hui d'avoir mis en danger des
sources en publiant une masse
d'informations classifiées le monde doit
se préparer à une éventuelle pandémie de
coronavirus indique l' oms l'inquiétude
après 150 nouveaux décès en chine où la
propagation décline néanmoins en france
il n'y a plus aucun malade hospitalisé
pour ce virus alors qu'un sixième
patient est mort en italie
onze villes du nord seront là sont
placés en quarantaine les retraites au
bout de huit jours d'examens l'assemblée
adopte le premier des soixante cinq
articles du projet de loi de réforme et
non sans suspension et rappelle à
l'ordre les avocats entament leur
septième semaine de grève ce qui a
entraîné le mrap report à mercredi du
procès de l'ex premier ministre françois
fillon et de son épouse pénélope dans la
sphère des soupçons d'emplois fictifs 1
au salon de l'agriculture c'était au
tour du premier ministre edouard
philippe de déambuler dans les allées
après la visite des manuels macron ce
week end un rendez vous incontournable
pour les politiques l approche des
municipales alors que le grand débat
national sur l'agriculture et la façon
d'utiliser les fonds européens qui lui
sont destinés à été lancé c'est un
premier déplacement officiel en inde
pour donald trump un accueil particulier
a été réservé au président américain
avec un meeting géant aux côtés de nara
maudit et l'escapade au taj mahal
les deux hommes affichent une entente
dans un contexte de vives tensions
commerciales entre les deux pays
[Musique]
julian assange sera-t-il extradé vers
les états unis premier jour du procès
pour le fondateur de wikileaks qui
comparaît depuis ce matin devant la
justice britannique
on doit décider de donner suite ou non à
la demande américaine de
d'extradition les précisions depuis
londres avec notre reporter monnaie à
modena
il faudra attendre plusieurs semaines
pour connaître le sort du lanceur en
alerte julian assange qui est incarcéré
à la prison juste derrière moi la prison
belmarsh au sud de londres pour rappel
il a été il est accusé par les états
unis et d'espionnage pour avoir révélé
plusieurs documents confidentiels
concernant l'activité de l'armée
américaine en irak et en afghanistan
l'audience a d'abord débuté par l
accusation 30 minutes ont été accordés à
la défense il faut savoir que pendant
toute cette journée d'audience julian
assange n'a jamais pu prendre la parole
ne serait ce que pour se défendre il
faut également mentionner que plusieurs
rassemblements dans le monde entier
également à londres ont été organisées
en soutien de julian assange des gilets
jaunes étaient présents ici des anglais
mais également des allemands et
plusieurs personnes venues d'autres pays
pour soutenir
julian assange plusieurs champs ont été
entendus comme fruit assange à savoir l
libérez assange
le père de julian assange est également
venu à cette audition il était
extrêmement ému par la présence
médiatique mais également par les
soutiens qu'ils étaient venus ici pour
cette audience je vous propose de
l'écouter
après 10 ans d'enquêté
dix ans l'afer a été abandonné les
charges ont été abandonnées
ils étaient quatre procureurs vous avez
bien vu tout cela
il n'a fallu que huit ans pour mettre un
homme sur la lune dix ans
le dernier élément reste l'accusation
contre julian d'avoir aidé chelsea
manning une fête à son procès celle ci a
parlé de sa motivation et de sa décision
délibérée de se tourner vers julian et
wikileaks et de se mettre en contact
avec lui afin de laisser fuiter ces
documents préoccupant abordant des
injustices et des crimes de guerre vous
l'avez entendu le père de julian assange
qui s'est exprimé à la fin de cette
audience il a également eu des avocats
et en l'occurrence le rédacteur en chef
de wikileaks qui estime que l'affairé
assange et tag est un cas politique il
alerte également sur l'état de santé du
fondateur de wikileaks qui ne fait que
se dégrader il a parlé de dépression
mais également de risque de suicide
écoutez le il n'y a rien de nouveau rien
que nous n'avons pas déjà entendu en
disant cette accusation de faire du mal
en exposant le crime de guerre
le mal fait en irak en afghanistan c'est
une allégation qui ne tenait pas la
route il ya dix ans et qui ne tient
certainement pas la route aujourd'hui et
c'est une tactique de propagande pour
détourner l'attention sur le fait que
wikileaks avait exposé des crimes des
crimes de guerre grave
il faudra donc patienter plusieurs
semaines avant de connaître le verdict
aux etats unis
julian assange fait face à 18 chefs
d'accusation il encourt jusqu'à 175 ans
de prison prêt depuis son lancement en
2006 par julian assange wikileaks a donc
été mis en lumière
non ah non pardon a mis en lumière de
nombreux cas d'espionnage ou de
violations des droits humains retour en
images sur les scandales les plus
retentissants
[Musique]
où
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
pour en parler nous sommes avec anthony
bellanger secrétaire général de la
fédération internationale des
journalistes bonsoir anthony bellanger
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france
à quoi doit-on s'attendre avec ce procès
et bien c'est toute la question de la
justice
si la justice notamment britanniques et
est indépendante et si elle elle va
juger cette extradition valable ou non
compte tenu des charges qui qui qui sont
aujourd'hui sur sur le cas de julian
assange
je reste très optimiste puisque
quelqu'un et qu'il irait le droit
international de façon classique
comprendre est tout simplement qu' il
n'y a aucune charge contre lui
aujourd'hui que s'il faut quand même
savoir de quoi on parle on parle de
l'intérêt général d'information destinée
au public et non de évidemment
d'espionnage comme les américains
tentent de le démontrer aujourd'hui vous
avez justement évoqué la pression qui
règne sur ce procès la pression
médiatique est ce que dans ces
conditions la justice américaine avant
anglaise britanniques peuvent répondre
dans des conditions sereines
oui je j'espère en tout cas que la
justice anglaise est indépendante
ce qui n'est évidemment pas le cas de
des cours de justice qui attendrait
julian assange en virginie s'il devait
être extradé dans dans l'année où là on
est vraiment là au nord dans nos sièges
réellement delà de l'année c'est
notamment donc là on sait qu'il y aura
des dépressions qui seront autres et ils
sont évidemment politique dont
concernant la justice anglaise c'est une
des cours de justice les plus reconnues
dans le monde et on peut vraiment
espérer le plus sincèrement possible que
quelqu'un soit favorable en tout cas
qu'à 10 le droit tel que nous le côté
des défenseurs de julian assange à nous
tous nous consommons vous ne craignez
donc pas anthony bellanger aujourd'hui
un procès politique
si bien entendu qu'on ne craint toujours
mais
tenu de la position qui est la mienne
aujourd'hui je suis naturellement
optimiste compte tenu de la situation
des journalistes dans le monde constitue
compte tenu de la situation de la presse
dans le monde
je me dois en tant qu sg soit un général
de la fédération internationale de
rester optimiste pour ce que la
situation est vraiment catastrophique
dans beaucoup d'endroits je dis souvent
d'aidé julian assange il y en a à peu
près 360 dans le monde d'un crd
personnes qui sont en prison parce
qu'ils ont voulu le vrai pour la
profession et qu'ils ont voulu remplir
leur mission d'informer la situation de
la nation je dépasse ce cadre évidemment
des prisonniers habituel puisque bien
entendu si l'extradition est acceptée
c'est vraiment là la justice américaine
qui fera qui prendra le pas sur la
justice
les différentes justice nationale de
l'europe et en l'occurrence c'est une
conséquence assez grave pour tous les
journalistes de demain qui voudront
travailler sur des documents que les
américains auront jugé ou aurait jugé
défense nationale sauf que leurs
représentants des états unis zhang fei
louise dit
lui julian assange n'est pas un
journaliste qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez bien coûter je ne sais pas si
ce monsieur est habilité à dire qui est
outil n'est pas journaliste
en l'occurrence moi en tant que
responsables de sa fédération
internationale on a la plus grande
fédération mondiale de journalistes qui
sont représente 600 mille personnes dans
le monde
julian assange a et membres de notre
fédération australienne dans notre
fédération de la presse australienne
donc à amy et il est détenteur de la
carte de presse internationale que
juillet moi même que j'ai moi même si et
d'ailleurs j'ai vu dans différentes
images qui ont été publiées sur les
différents fils que cette carte de
presse internationale était était
affiché un peu partout et puis il a fait
il a fait un travail de gens et c'est à
dire les informations qu'il a qu'il a
donné jusqu'à maintenant ils sont
absolument exact personne ne remet en
cause la véracité des milliers des
millions même de la formation qui l'a
t-il a publié donc en tant que rédacteur
en chef de wikileaks entend aussi que
c'est et ce pour quoi il est il est
accusé aujourd'hui c'est à dire d'avoir
montré cette vidéo notamment en attaque
celle ci mais cette vidéo que latéral
mode avant de la fille diffusées il faut
savoir que ils se sont enfermés dans une
série house à reykjavik en islande pour
vraiment travaillé sur le détail pour
voir si t'es pas un faux après ils ont
travaillé avec deux journalistes de
wikileaks sont allés sur place pour
essayer de se rendre compte qu'ils
étaient les militaires qui ont tireront
qui ont ils été dans la lah d'un
hélicoptère apache qui étaient les
militaires qui ont été assassinés
évidemment qu'ils étaient les militaires
et les civils et les enfants qui ont été
assassinés sur place dont tu fais un
travail de journaliste cet effet s'il a
vérifié tout simplement la source qu'il
avait il l'a publié
donc je vois pas ce que on pourrait
faire de plus quand on est quand on est
journaliste et vous comme moi nous vous
savez qu'un journaliste doit d'abord
avant de publier son information
vérifier ses sources c'est ce qu'il a
fait donc une fois encore il est gênant
cet homme est gênant c'est un procès
politique qui l'attend ça on l'a déjà
dit tout le monde le sait et il est
clair va essayer de le bâillonner le
plus vite possible alors le rapporteur
de l'onu sur la torture nil semaine
skis mais on est dernier qu'il
présentait julian assange tous les
symptômes typiques d'une exposition
prolongée à la torture psychologique est
ce que son état de santé lui permet de
bien suivre ce procès c'est à prendre en
compte
absolument vous avez raison j'ai encore
été en lien avec son père il ya deux
jours que vous venez que vous avez eue
interviewé tout à l'heure et il m'a
confirmé effectivement que l'état de
santé de son fils n'était pas bon et
qu'il il avait vraiment de grandes
craintes et c'était c'était d'ailleurs
une des informations déjà temps des mois
l'ouverture de ce procès de julien
l'instant chez de voir dans quel état
physique il allait être et que ce soit
ses conseils internationaux de sortie
france en belgique au royaume uni
tous sont assez inquiets de la santé de
julian assange effectivement le le
rapporteur spécial des nations unies
avec qui j'ai participé à beaucoup de
d'intervention au conseil de l'europe
mais aussi au parlement européen sans
son avis et n'est pas que la vie d'un
rapporteur spécial sur la torture
c'est l'avis de médecins cela-dit de
psychiatres et de psychologues qui qui
ont montré qu'ils simplement que c'est
cette personne là et elle était sous
torture psychologique la torture
psychologique selon les médecins ses
quinze jours d'isolement
julian assange est resté neuf mois donc
on peut voir tout simplement les dégâts
et je crains qu'il y ait des dégâts
irréparables sur 7 sur 7 sur ses
collègues merci beaucoup anthony
bellanger d'avoir été en direct avec mon
secrétaire général de la fédération
internationale des journalistes merci à
vous
l'inquiétude mondial face aux
coronavirus 150 nouveaux décès
enregistrés en chine le pays n'avait pas
signalé autant de morts depuis 11 jours
près de 2600 personnes au total ont
perdu la vie depuis la fin décembre mais
on note tout de même un déclin dans la
propagation de virus en chine
ailleurs dans le monde la corée du sud
est désormais le plus grand foyer de
l'épidémie avec sept morts et 763
personnes contaminées puis vient l'iran
où le virus a fait 12 morts selon un
dernier bilan le koweït bahreïn l'irak
et l'afghanistan a aussi annoncé leurs
premiers cas d'infection
l'organisation mondiale de la santé tire
la sonnette d'alarmé demande au monde de
se préparer à une éventuelle pandémie du
virus et lors d'un point presse ce soir
olivier verront le nouveau ministre de
la santé s'est voulu rassurant il a
rappelé qu'à l'heure qu'il est il n'y a
plus aucun cas connus de contamination
france il n'y a ce soir pas de
circulation du virus sur le territoire
national c'est important de le rappeler
car notre stratégie est fonction du
niveau de risque
elle est surtout je lisais hier soir
adaptable et révisable à tout moment
aujourd'hui tout est mis en place pour
freiner l'introduction dû virus sur le
territoire par le dépistage des cas
possibles notamment
nous avons augmenté considérablement nos
capacités diagnostic
comme je le disais par l' isolement des
malades et je vous annonce qu'il n'y a
ce soir plus aucun malade hospitalisé en
france le dernier patient qui était
hospitalisé à lyon est guéri n'est plus
contagieux et a pu rentrer chez lui et
par les enquêtes de terrain comme ce qui
a été brillamment organisé à contamines
montjoie grâce à la mobilisation de
toutes les équipes sanitaires des
agences régionales de santé les
problèmes de santé libéraux et
hospitaliers
inquiétude également en italie où le
virus a fait un sixième or il avait 80
ans la situation est préoccupante dans
le nord du pays notamment confrontait
une
hausse des cas de contamination onze
communes ont été placés en quarantaine
une mesure de restriction pour limiter
la propagation du virus françois tessier
beach
à milan sur la piazza del duomo des
tories sont refusés devant l'entrée de
la cathédrale écoles universités mais
aussi musées cinémas et théâtres dont la
prestigieuse scala sont fermés jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
les bars baisseront le rideau de 18h à
6h du matin des mesures que comprennent
les milanais il s'agit d'une mesure de
précaution total et je pense donc que
cette décision a été importante bien
qu'elle soit drastique à certains égards
mais étant donné la situation il ne faut
ni sous-estimer ni surestimer ce qui
nous arrive
la fermeture des principaux espaces
publics peut être un choix équitables
partageable ou non c'est certainement
une bonne précaution si quelque chose
est fermé pendant quelques jours il ne
se passe rien à 60 kilomètres de là la
police effectue des contrôles routiers à
l'entrée de la ville de casa pu
sterlingot situe à quelques kilomètres
de codognan la ville considéré comme le
foyer de l'épidémie de la péninsule
aucune voiture ne peut entrer et sortir
les 15000 habitants se retrouvent peu à
peu coupé du monde
seules les pharmacies et quelques
supermarchés reste ouvert même si ses
clients ont eu moins de chance
alors qu'il devait rouvrir ce lundi ce
magasin est finalement resté portes
closes des supermarchés qui sont pris
d'assaut comme ici à rozzano où les
clients littéralement dévalisé les
rayons
au total depuis samedi ce sont plus de
cinquante mille personnes qui vivent
confinés pour tenter d'éviter la
propagation du virus
a venise les derniers jours du carnaval
ont été annulées
il devait se dérouler jusqu'à mardi et
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec le docteur gerald kerzec médecin
urgentiste bon soit en général de merci
de ce nom en direct sur la réponse
d'avoir pris le temps ont changé plex
alors que vous êtes de garde ce soir on
vous avez interrogé ici même il ya deux
semaines vous étiez assez rassurant
estimant qu'on en faisait peut-être un
peu trop parfois que vous inspirent les
derniers développements est-ce qu'on
doit être encore sommes sereins
rassurant il faut l'être parce que comme
l'a rappelé les différents émises de la
santé il n'y a pas de cas sur le
territoire deuxièmement les patients qui
sont décédés en italie étaient des
patients extrêmement fragilisée à des
patients de plus de 70 voire 80 ans donc
ce qu'on a toujours dit et côté médical
c'est ce virus il est probablement
extrêmement contagieux mais comme l'est
la grippe par exemple la grippe est
extrêmement contagieuse
après la question c'est la virulence de
ce virus est ce que ce virus attaque
affaiblie des gens qui sont en bonne
santé ou au contraire est délétère et
virulent chez des gens qui sont
fragilisés pour l'instant à dater en
tout cas sur les cas en italie
cela confirme ce sont plutôt des
patients qui sont déjà fragilisés et
déjà des patients âgés donc les choses
ne changent pas le virus
il est très contagieux il est probable
et c'est ce que rappelle l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qu'on va avoir
affaire à une diffusion rapide
j'emploie le mot de pandémie à une
diffusion mondiale le pont est le mot
pandémie fait peur mais en réalité une
pandémie chaque année en à une pandémie
ça s'appelle la grippe donc la
contagiosité elle est certaine mais pour
l'instant la virulence elle n'est pas
plus exceptionnelle que ça alors le
député on l'a entendu ça a pris une
tournure un petit peu politique
aujourd'hui le député maire eric ciotti
qui réclame au premier ministre un plan
d'urgence rétablissent demandant le
rétablissement des frontières mais en
tout cas un contrôle eux accéléré aux
frontières terrestres avec des contrôles
à la clé en tant que médecin ça vous
fait sourire ce genre de propositions
non
non ça fait pas ce en fait là deux
choses il ya la partie médicale
virologique street et c'est clair qu'un
virus ne va pas s'arrêter à la frontière
et puis avec un de la partie politique
au sens politique de santé et de gestion
des foules et j'ai de gestion notamment
de la panique potentiel parce qu'on voit
bien que la température est montée d'un
cran sans mauvais jeu de mots avec
l'italie notre voisin proche avec des
gens on avait eu cette remarque à propos
de la chine et des vols où on avait
beaucoup reproché qui est peut être
contrôle de température par exemple à la
descente d avion et c'est vrai qu'en
tant que citoyen on peut comprendre que
les gens auraient aimé être rassurés en
ayant même si on sait que c'est pas
efficace à 100 %
le fait d'avoir des contrôles de
température ça permet peut-être d'avoir
quelques cas potentiels qui seraient des
pistes et on sait que ça n'a pas une
efficacité à 100% mais ça permet de
montrer déjà que la situation est prise
au sérieuse que les autorités contrôlent
un certain nombre de choses et
éventuellement sur le plan médical de
repérer un certain nombre de patientes
de pouvoir les isoler on est encore dans
une phase en france on peut isoler les
patients la fenêtre de tir elle va être
relativement courte parce que on voit
bien qu'en italie ils sont à plus de 200
cas plus on a des cas qui se multiplient
plus l'enjeu n'est plus finalement de
les isoler mais vraiment de les traiter
voyez bien ici on a plusieurs centaines
de patients ça va être compliqué de les
isoler on n'imagine pas pour la grippe
par exemple isolé tout le monde donc
cette mesure contrôle des frontières
voire de fermeture des frontières je
pense pas qu'en france en pis
fermer les frontières mais elle aura un
côté symbolique qui serait peut-être pas
inutile ce contrôle de température ne
serait ce que pour rassurer les gens
mais on est bien d'accord que sur le
plan médical c'est pas ça qui empêchera
la diffusion du virus ce virus il est
très contagieux on le voit en italie on
sait même pas quel est le patient zéro
en télé le patient source ce virus il
est il a été transporté véhicules et de
chine
et on voit bien que ça paraît
extrêmement difficile de maintenir une
situation hermétique en france avec zéro
cas sur le territoire
justement pour parler de cette isolation
entre guillemets des patients et en
italie il ya onze villes qui sont en
quarantaine en france le dispositif
sanitaire des alpes-maritimes a été
renforcé les écoliers les collégiens
mais aussi les lycéens qui sont revenus
des pays comme la chine les pays touchés
la corée du nord mais même justement le
nord de l'italie ne doivent pas
réintégrer les crèches les écoles et les
lycées avant un délai de 14 jours
c'est pas un petit peu beaucoup il n'y a
pas une psychose tout de même qu'ils
aient s'installe où on est quand même
dans la bonne direction
alors comme on a zéro cas sur le
territoire on est dans une phase où si
jamais il ya un cas où quelques cas
isolés il faut à tout prix les contenir
pour éviter qu'ils ne contaminent
ailleurs dont d'où l'idée de maintenir
ces gens n'ont pas en quarantaine en
isolement à domicile en parle
d'isolement à domicile de confinement et
c'est la meilleure technique vers si
vous êtes contagieux avec la grippe ou
avec le co vide 19 ce coronavirus le
meilleur moyen de ne pas refiler à votre
voisin passé de ne pas côtoyer votre
voisin danse et de rester confinés à
domicile c'est pas la quarantaine c'est
pas la ville qui est sous quarantaine
laisser les personnes à risque qui sont
mis en isolement à domicile et qui sont
réapprovisionnés par exemple en
nourriture évidemment et puis
si jamais il ya des symptômes à ce
moment là ils peuvent être pris en
charge tout de suite pourquoi le délai
de quatre à quatorze jours un délai qui
est discutable parce que ce délai de 14
jours c'est le délai d'incubation qu'on
suppose le délai maximal le seul
problème c'est qu'il commence à y avoir
un certain nombre de papiers
scientifiques qui montrent que ce délai
d'incubation il est plus élevé que ça il
est jusqu'à 20 voire 27 jours ce qui
pousserait peut-être a changé un peu la
limite et pourquoi pas les isoler les
gens un peu plus longtemps
je disais on est dans cette phase où on
peut encore isolées les gens imaginent
on conçoit comme en italie ou dans des
pays où ils comme la chine par exemple
où vous avez beaucoup de cas des
centaines de cas ça pose le problème
derrière de où les isoler et on voit
bien qu'on ne peut pas on peut les
isoler à la maison on peut ne peut pas
les isoler à l'hôpital parce que les
chambres d'isolement elles sont pas avec
un nombre infini et puis moi je suis
quand même il ya quelque chose qui
m'inquiète c'est se passant de 38 ans en
italie qui est peut-être le patient
c'est à dire le premier patient pas le
patient qui aurait introduit le virus
mais ce premier patient qui a été
contaminé on sait pas bien par qui mais
en tout cas se passait il a 38 ans donc
il est jeune il n'a pas d'antécédents
médicaux et ce patient il est en
réanimation est donc là se poseraient la
question si ce virus attaque ou
s'attaque à des jeunes gens et les
conduit à des situations de détresse
vitale qui les conduisent en réanimation
se posera la question dans notre pays
d'une la capacité de réanimation de lits
de réanimation et là on est sur un autre
problème on est plus sur un poème
d'isoler les gens cercil le nombre
dépasse le nombre dépasse les capacités
d'isolement c'est ce sont les capacités
hospitalières et en particulier de lits
de réanimation et deux ventilateurs pour
pouvoir apporter de l'oxygène à ses
patients qui va se poser très rapidement
l'instant on n'en est pas là on en est
sûr les premiers cas il faut à tout prix
les isoler mais rapidement si la
situation se confirme et si on a des cas
en france
il va falloir penser à dimensionner les
lits de réanimation dernière question un
gerald kerzec où on est le vaccin
alors pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
vaccin on est sur des traitements qui
sont des traitements symptomatiques
les chercheurs sont allés très vite ils
ont isolé ils ont génotypés ils ont
génotypés le virus il ya quelques essais
cliniques un peu partout dans le monde
notamment une équipe australienne qui
développerait un vaccin alors entre la
phase 2 on trouve le vaccin et la mise
en production de ce vaccin vous pensez
bien qu'il peut se passer beaucoup de
semaine voir beaucoup de moi la deuxième
chose c'est que ce sont des virus donc
ces virus sont capable de muter
extrêmement rapidement on le connaît
très bien avec la grippe quand vous avez
la grippe qui est avec un cocktail de
vaccin avec des souches de grippe est
malheureusement très souvent le vaccin
tape parfois un peu à côté parce que
vous avez le virus qui va être capable
de muter
donc c'est peut-être un peu le problème
aux cycles kobe de 19 notamment les
souches en iran qui serait dé souche
beaucoup plus virulente
donc le vaccin on n'y est pas encore des
chercheurs font des essais cliniques
entre la phase de recherches et la phase
de développement et de fabrication
il va s'écouler un certain délai et puis
encore une fois que les réserves que ce
virus ne mute pas plus vite que ne
trouve les chercheurs une solution de
vaccination merci beaucoup général de
kiev d'avoir été avec nous on vous
libère vous pouvez retourner à votre
garde merci d'avoir pris ces quelques
minutes pour le temps du direct merci à
vous restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de la réforme
des retraites et des avocats qui
entament leur septième semaine de
mobilisation et puis reviendront sur le
salon de l'agriculture qui a vu
aujourd'hui déambuler le premier
ministre après la visite du président
macron ce week-end
[Musique]
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'atterrissage quelque chose a cassé
le train d'atterrissage ouais c'est
compliqué l'aérodrome et glacé les gars
ça commence à m'énerver
on a battu voile au regard notamment pas
fait attention et quelle est la
profondeur si on tombe des 4000 m
nestor j'espère qu'ils pourront obtenir
des données uniques sur le champ
magnétique
mais ça c'est le toit du monde
cela veut dire que tout est possible
les gens ici m'ont fortement étonné
c'est collectif c'est une véritable
équipe dont les membres sont prêts à
travailler sans broncher bolides et ses
nerfs pour à vue de nez pour que tout se
passe comme près
[Musique]
20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez en france nouvelle
semaine de débats sur le projet de
réforme des retraites à l'assemblée
nationale le premier des soixante cinq
articles du projet de loi était adopté
sous les applaudissements de la majorité
entre rappels au règlement et
suspensions de séance à la répétition et
leur a fallu 70 heures de débat pour
venir à bout des quelques deux mille
deux cents amendements et
sous-amendement déposées principalement
par les oppositions sur cet article il a
été invalidé par 89 voix contre 46 et
les avocats restent en tout cas vent
debout contre la réforme de leur régime
autonome de retraite ils sont plusieurs
dizaines à avoir bloqué ce matin les
entrées du tribunal de paris
les annonces la semaine dernière de
nicole belloubet n'ont pas suffi à
apaiser leur colère la garde des sceaux
a déposé un amendement qui prévoit
d'instaurer un dispositif de solidarité
des avocats objectif faire baisser le
montant des cotisations pour ceux dont
le revenu est inférieur à 80 milles
euros annuels pas suffisant selon ses
avocats combat entendre comme vous le
savez les avocats sont mobilisés à tout
le moins depuis le 6 janvier par une
grève dure et générale de tous les
barreaux de france contre le projet de
réforme des retraites nous faisons
renvoyer tous les dossiers nous
désignons plus les avocats à l'aide
juridictionnelle et maintenant nous
allons passer à l'étape supérieure
c'est-à-dire bloqué l'entrée des
juridictions ce sont nos juridictions
c'est là où on travaille tous les jours
et donc pour essayer de nous faire
entendre puisque madame b loubet et le
gouvernement de monsieur macro ne nous
entendent pas eh bien nous passerons à
la vitesse supérieure nous avons appris
que le parlement envisage de faire voter
la réforme des retraites avec le 49-3 eh
bien nous nous sortons notre 49,3 qui
consiste à bloquer le palais de justice
parce que nous sommes dans une situation
de blocage absolu les 70000 avocats de
france sont en grève
croyez-moi si les 70000 avocats de
france sont en grève ce n'est pas pour
le plaisir c'est parce que notre
profession notre métier risque de
disparaître en tout cas un tiers des
avocats de france risquent de
disparaître
avec l'augmentation de la cotisation qui
est prévu dans la réforme des retraites
ne repentant du cénb ils sont reçus par
la chancellerie qui dit toujours la même
chose
c'est à dire des âneries qui nous
propose des choses qui sont parfaitement
inacceptables qui nous demande de
financer en réalité le passage au
système universel ce qui est
inacceptable
on peut pas demander un avocat de voir
ses cotisations doublée
c'est pension baisser sans qu'ils
fassent rien et je crains que le
gouvernement n'ait pas bien compris qu
on lâchera rien
même s'ils font du canon s'ils font
passer le 49-3 prêt pour en parler nous
sommes avec leïla amazonie avocat
président d'honneur de l'union des
jeunes avocats de paris bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous on a entendu cette
colère un de vos confrères aujourd'hui
le 49-3 vous le craignez vous aussi oui
on le craint parce que c'est le point
d'orgue c'est la fin d'un processus qui
a été dans une absence totale de raids
dialogue réel et de concertation et
c'est la négation du débat parlementaire
et du débat républicain et c'est
effectivement quelque chose qui nous
inquiète dans un contexte où on est très
éprouvé par les conditions dans
lesquelles cette réforme semaine alors
ce qui frappe chez vous c'est que c'est
vrai que ça fait la septième semaine
maintenant de mobilisation vous vous
dites entre 4 vous n'êtes pas entendu
par la garde des sceaux en tout cas par
le par le gouvernement comment vous vous
l'expliquer il ya probablement plusieurs
raisons c'est assez compliqué c'est
vraiment un dialogue de sourds c'est
très irritant le moi mon explication à
tout personnel c'est que c'est que de la
com derrière la garde des sceaux elle
n'a rien n'à offrir et ce sont que des
éléments de langage des petites saillies
des agressions
des dénigrements où nous infantilise
mais en réalité derrière ça il n'y a
aucun moyen sur un projet qui est mal
rédigée mal préparé et complètement
impossible à contrôler pour eux est-ce
que vous vous sentez particulièrement
mais les mets à part par le gouvernement
c'est vrai que l'exécutif a lâché sur
plusieurs professions dans les
transports notamment les danseurs les
pompiers les policiers
il ya des promesses parle aux billets
pour les professeurs de revalorisation
de leurs salaires
et vous les avocats alors je pense que
déjà
moi je suis un peu plus modérées sur ce
qui a été lâchée pour les autres
professions parce que quand on regarde
si on prend des professions qui était
dans le collectif sos retraite qui en
sont sortis parce qu'ils avaient obtenu
des choses et qui finalement n'ont rien
obtenu de réelles
c'est toujours la même chose la
différence entre nous c'est que
effectivement on a résisté et que nous
on sait lire un texte où tout ne
présente un abonnement ou une
proposition qui n'en est pas une
on sait dire que c'est que c'est que
c'est un abus et c'est ça je pense la
différence essentielle et c'est pour ça
qu effectivement il ya un mépris
grandissant parce qu'au lieu de répondre
à sa part une réflexion profonde sur les
alertes ont fait la réaction c'est ce
que je vous disais c'est nous
infantiliser nous mépriser et c'est vrai
qu'on le vit particulièrement mal on a
entendu un de vos confrères dire voilà
on veut nous doubler ça fera foi de pour
nos cotisations
vous avez eu vous concernant est
vraiment une étude d'impact très
précises parce que c'est rare les
français qui sèchent vraiment qu'ils
savent vraiment pardon
comment ils vont être mangés la source
de cette nouvelle réforme alors le
doublement le terme de doublement il
vient du taux de cotisation
puisqu'aujourd'hui on a à peu près à 14%
et on va passer à 28 % donc x 2 même si
madame bello b ne compte pas comme nous
14 x 2 ça fait bien 28 ans est bien sûr
un doublement et il n'y a pas d'étude
d'impact un réellement du gouvernement
ils ont
fourni des chiffres des exemples types
qui était pas du tout réaliste qui était
pas ce qu'on avait demandé et l'étude
d'impact est complètement vide
en revanche nous on a une chambre qui
nous a fait une simulation effectivement
d'ailleurs que le gouvernement leur a
intimé de retirer tellement ça les
arrangeait pas et les résultats sont
catastrophiques c'est à dire que ça ça à
remontrer à la profession combien la
situation était catastrophique et
combien ça n'avait absolument pas été
anticipée alors la ministre de la
justice dont vous parlez beaucoup à
préciser qu'il n'y aura pas de au sein
de cotisation pour les avocats qu'ils
gagnent jusqu'à 80 mille euros de
revenus par an le faut juste ou alors
pas suffisant pas acceptable pour vous
c'est fois parce que leurs chiffres son
four c'est à dire qu'ils font des
calculs par rapport à des comparaisons
de cotisation qui n'existe pas je vous
donne un exemple très simple
oui il faut une projection
d'augmentation de nos cotisations de
notre régime autonome au delà de 2029
alors que cette augmentation elle
n'existe pas et il n'y a aucune raison
d'exister à partir de là il vous invente
une augmentation ils vous disent
regarder quand on compare avec 7,1
augmentation inventé ben vous êtes
finalement pas si mal loti ça fait que 5
points alors déjà que cinq points c'est
déjà énorme
et en plus un prêtre en réalité c'est
beaucoup plus est-ce que vous accusez
clairement le gouvernement de
malhonnêteté de négligence
d'incompétence quand ils proposaient des
mauvais chiffres et a vraiment une
volonté de tromper selon vous moi je
pense qu'il ya plusieurs choses
il y a mon sentiment profond c'est
qu'ils n'ont de toute façon pas de bis
ils ont rien à donner donc en fait ne
peuvent que tourner autour de chiffres
qui représente
après je pense qu'il ya quand même une
vraie malhonnêteté intellectuelle parce
que il ya eu plusieurs réunions
techniques on a souligné des difficultés
très importantes comme le fait qu'ils
avaient oublié notre retraite
complémentaire donc il compare des
choses qui ne sont pas comparables ou
qu'ils avaient oublié les jeunes avocats
qui ont des exonérations de cotisations
pendant cinq ans qui se retrouve avec
plus qu'un doublement pendant cinq ans
qu'yves qui est catastrophique pour eux
et ces choses là ils les ont les ont
acté et ils n'ont jamais rien changé à
leur calcul parce que ils doivent à tout
prix faire admettre nous faire admettre
ils veulent à tout prix nous faire
admettre que c'est bien pour nous alors
la ministre de la justice elle est en
tout cas le déplore que la grève des
avocats se prolonge à partir du moment
je cite où nous avons fait des
propositions c'était ce matin chez nos
confrères d'rtl vous lui répondez quoi
ce soir nicole belloubet a que faire des
propositions de papiers à des avocats
qui savent lire la loi c'est pas
forcément une bonne idée il ya deux
propositions finales au départ il y en
avait plus mais elle était tellement
tellement irréalisable et irréalistes
qui les ont pas maintenu il ya une
proposition qui est un abattement
mais en fait un abattement sur une
assiette plus large donc en fait c'est
un abattement très faible et cet
abattement il est inconstitutionnel
on le sait depuis des semaines on le dit
depuis des semaines que ça ne peut pas
être fait comme ça et et ils le
maintiennent donc ils savent
parfaitement ses actes et on a fait
toutes les démonstrations techniques que
ce sera invalidée par le conseil
constitutionnel et il le met quand même
donc vous voyez bien l'affront qui est
fait en vous disant ma voyez vous avez
une concession et vous devez les
accepter et la deuxième concession c'est
un fonds de solidarité
on vous dira ça c'est quand même bien
vous avez un fonds de solidarité mais le
fonds de solidarité vous savez par qui
il est financé par nous c'est à dire que
nous devons nous-mêmes payer les effets
néfastes de la delà de la réforme des
retraites
et quand on dit mais c'est un finançable
on nous dit mais pas du tout c'est très
bien et vous l'avez peut-être vu il a
circulé beaucoup on a trois quarts et de
flèches en disant regardez c'est sans
fond solidarité on a pas un seul
élément chiffré on sait qu' il n'y aura
pas d'amendement de l'état pas
d'amendement deux tiers on va devoir le
financer tout seul et qui en a pour des
milliards donc en réalité ils peuvent
nous le m ils peuvent nous dire soit
vous mettez vos réserves soit vous
mettez vos réserves
mais même si on fait ça en fait ce sera
pas ce sera pas faisable donc c'est
encore une proposition de papier
aujourd'hui on imagine votre inquiétude
puisqu'on en parle est un ce 49 3 3 get
iliad et finalement des actions est ce
qu'elles sont suffisamment nuisible pour
faire bouger
l'exécutif qui ne semble pas vouloir
accorder plus de concessions il ya le
procès fillon l'a qui a fait parler d'où
un qui est reporté bref est ce que vos
actions sont suffisamment médiatisé est
ce qu'elle suffise à faire bouger les
lignes
selon vo je ne sais pas si ça va suffire
parce qu'on est sur un gouvernement
excessivement dogmatique et encore une
fois je pense qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens c'est à dire que leur réservent
leurs efforts mais tellement pas
financées qui ne peuvent pas même
envisagé de préserver le régime autonome
fusse-t-il bénéficiaires et fusse-t-il
solidaire donc je pense que ça va pas
faire bouger les lignes franchement de
leur côté ils n'ont ils n'ont pas les
moyens de toutes façons de changer leur
position mais en revanche ce qui change
c'est clairement l'opinion publique est
aussi aussi la justice au sens large
c'est-à-dire les cette mobilisation des
avocats qu'est ce qu'elle a montré c'est
que la justice est en train de mourir
comme l'hôpital public par défaut de
moyens et que quand les avocats ne
jouent plus le jeu c'est à dire de
pallier les manquements du service
public
ça tient pas trois semaines et ça
commence à fissurer de toutes parts et
les magistrats et les greffiers nous
soutiennent est ce que ça montre c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a une justice
excessivement pauvre un système
excessivement déficitaire et une justice
de classe
est ce que ça montre ce mouvement c'est
ça est-ce que ça permet de créer c'est
une solidarité et aussi une
sensibilisation de l'opinion publique il
faut souligner que c'est très rare de
voir autant d'avocats mobiliser contre
un texte le gouvernement merci antemeta
elle est là
david avoir été avec nous avocats
président d'honneur de l'union des
jeunes avocats de paris merci à vous une
conséquence de cette contestation des
avocats de très attendu procès fillon on
en parlait à l'instant qui devait
débuter aujourd'hui a été renvoyée à
mercredi l'ancien premier ministre et
son épouse ainsi que marc joulaud ancien
suppléant de françois fillon à
l'assemblée nationale vont comparaître
dans la sphère des emplois présumés
fictifs de pénélope fillon les
précisions de notre reporter katia
technique
le procès de l'ancien premier ministre
françois fillon a été renvoyé au 26
février à 13h30
les trois avocats des prévenus avaient
demandé un renvoi en solidarité à la
grève des avocats contre la réforme des
retraites
lors de l'audience à 13h30 m antonin
lévy la défense de françois fillon a dit
vouloir exprimer sa sympathie envers ses
confrères donc renvoie les trois
prévenus sont sortis de la salle
d'audience sans faire de déclaration
marc joulaud et françois fillon étaient
poursuivis pour détournement de fonds
publics
pénélope fillon pour recel et complicité
et en outre le couple fillon sera
poursuivi pour complicité et recel
d'abus de biens sociaux
en effet pénélope fillon est accusé
d'avoir perçu plus d'un million d'euros
de fonds publics entre 1998 et 2000 13
en étant assistante parlementaire un
emploi possiblement fictifs alors pour
cela les trois prévenus encourent
jusqu'à dix ans de prison et de fortes
amendes et une peine d'inéligibilité
nous avons interviewé m if claisse qui
est l'avocat de l'assemblée nationale et
qui évoque la question du remboursement
mais ce n'est pas une première
pour l'assemblée nationale que de
demander le remboursement de
rémunération qui serait considérée par
la justice
encore une fois à son organe n'a pas de
pouvoir de police c'est l'application
d'une doctrine traditionnelle qui
s'applique
de façon constante le canard enchaîné
avait dévoilé en janvier 2017 ces
soupçons d'emplois fictifs
ainsi de nombreux autres révélations
mais françois fillon n'avait pas
abandonné la course à la présidentielle
pour autant et ce malgré une mise en
examen
alors la sanction des urnes a été rude
puisque françois fillon n'a obtenu que
20 de 0 1% des suffrages au premier tour
il a donc été éliminé c'était la
première fois que la droite ne passait
pas le second tour lors de la cinquième
république et aujourd'hui ce procès
était très attendue par les citoyens il
n'y avait plus d'une centaine de
journalistes devant cette salle
d'audience c'est un procès qui est
également très attendue par la droite
qui a envie de tourner la page de la
sphère fillon qui avait sérieusement
entaché sa réputation
on a le salon de l'agriculture a ouvert
ses portes samedi l'occasion de mettre
en lumière le malaise généralisé du
monde agricole selon les chiffre près de
deux agriculteurs se suicident chaque
jour en france le gouvernement a
d'ailleurs confié au député de
lot-et-garonne une mission pour la
prévention du suicide agricole un sujet
signé ben hassen chébili avec rania
berrada et julien de la cour le sujet a
été abordé par emmanuel macron lors de
l'inauguration du salon de l'agriculture
parce que j'ai trouvé leur match
si elle manque de revenus perspective
selon les chiffres les plus récents de
la msa la sécurité sociale des
agriculteurs
il y a eu six en cinq suicides de
paysans au cours de l'année 2015 contre
150 car moyenne entre 2007 et 2011
un nombre en hausse qui traduit un
malaise croissant dans le monde agricole
ça s'explique par l'augmentation des
charges et puis nos produits qui sont
pas en cohérence qui soit incohérent par
rapport à nos charges voilà donc je
trouve que le mal il s'est fait surtout
depuis l'euro on a des charges qui sont
rendus qu'on payait en francs
aujourd'hui on les paye en euros alors
que nos produits ont prévalu et 2,6 et
demi après l'argent en fin d'une ère
entre le franc et l'euro tpiy boss et
plus en plus dures faut des structures
qui sont plus en plus grosse on est loin
de moins en moins de monde à travailler
dessus et puis bah c'est des charges qui
augmentent et puis comme le produit pour
rémunérer en fonction de ça tu me répète
mais ben voilà ça se comprend
notre boulot principal ce serait de
nourrir la population est aujourd'hui la
population nous tirent dessus à boulet
rouge à cause de la grille bashing donc
on nous prend pour des pour des
empoisonneurs pour des on a sans arrêt
des problèmes pour la maltraitance
animale et toutes ces choses là donc on
comprend ce répit que console qu'on
sente qu'on soit réellement soutenu par
le consommateur
aujourd'hui
on vient à paris c'est pour informer le
consommateur il parle et comment on
travaille mais on a le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui le salon à paris c'est
plus le zoo du parisien qu'autre chose
un malaise que semble avoir entendu
emmanuel macron le président français a
annoncé avoir confié à olivier damaisin
député de lot-et-garonne une mission
pour améliorer la prévention du suicide
agricole il devra rendre un rapport dans
les six prochains mois au premier
ministre et au ministre de l'agriculture
et de la santé et pour en parler de
sommet les agriculteurs nous sommes avec
périco légasse journaliste critique
gastronomique bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous périco légasse pour parler de ce
sujet mission parlementaire confiée donc
à un député par emmanuel macron vous
pensez qu'on va progresser avec ce type
de mission oui on sait très bien que les
missions parlementaires arrête tout de
suite du suicide et que ceux qui étaient
dans une misère et dans la détresse
rosiers de s'arrêter non une fois de
plus de gouvernement se moque se moque
du monde et là on donne une une
sensation un peu de un peu de mépris
parce que la situation est vraiment
grave on à ce salon de l'agriculture qui
est le salon de l'industrie agricole et
la grande distribution ou la partie
paysanne n'est qu'une devanture
folklorique pour amuser les visiteurs
puisque comme l'a brisé ses pinceaux et
on a tous les responsables de la
détresse agricole française les grandes
firmes multinationales les semenciers le
syndicat majoritaire qui depuis 40 ans
cogère l'agriculture française et le
gouvernement et a envoyé la culture
française dans le mur qui devrait être
l'agriculteur français doit être l'homme
le plus heureux du monde aujourd'hui il
ya une demande il ya un contexte il ya
un patrimoine agricole prodigieux du
savoir faire et surtout une tradition on
comprend pas comment on en arriver là si
ce n'est par un système économique
la globalisation bien entendu l'europe
qui marchent pas la préférence
communautaire ne bénéficie pas aux
agriculteurs français
on importe des produits étrangers dans
une concurrence déloyale et je voyais
tout à l'heure les paysans espagnols les
agriculteurs espagnols sont en révolte
puisque eux mêmes sont maintenant
victime des produits marocains d'afrique
du nord que la grande distribution
espagnol un pan de spine donc chacun son
tour bienvenue au club
et là c'est une un acte de cynisme les
différents gouvernements qui se
succèdent en france avec cette crise
agricole cette détresse agricole
c'est un cynisme et un mépris sans
comparaison on a du mal justement à
comprendre pourquoi les présidents les
politiques ne défendent pas plus ce qui
est de sorte de notre patrimoine pour
pour quelles raisons par lâcheté par
idéologie par manque de moyens par
hommes n'ont tout simplement ils n'ont
pas la marge de manoeuvre ils n'ont pas
la marge de manoeuvre parce qu'ils se
sont coupés ils ont renoncé à des
prérogatives à des leviers politiques
nationaux et on a soumis la rivière
française ça remonte à longtemps serment
aux gars à 168 l'acte unique européen
ce libre échange le marché ouvert fait
qu'on expose la rivière française à une
concurrence mondiale déloyale avec des
preuves des pays où l'on produit à
moindre coût et ce sont les conséquences
des fameux traités internationaux c'est
pour ça que les paysans français ne
veulent ni de settat ni du mercosur
parce que ça déjà se poser d'une
concurrence déloyale à laquelle ils
peuvent pas résister quand on produit
dans les pays d'amérique latine ou
ailleurs en asie des céréales ou des
fruits ou en afrique du nord à moindre
coût que ces produits arrivent sur le
marché français où les agriculteurs
français sont un peu on doive faire
faire à des normes environnementales des
normes nutritionnelles des normes
économiques tout à fait tout à fait
légitime
eh bien ils peuvent pas résister et
l'europe au lieu des protégés de créer
une préférence communautaire
au lieu de faire une réglementation un
peu protectrice de la culture européenne
pas seulement française eh bien on ouvre
la culture française on la soumet on la
jette en pâture au marché international
et on laisse rentrer les produits qui
ruine les paysans c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui condamnées au suicide
on sait très bien comment ça va finir
et tant qu'on ne remettra pas en cause
cette europe qui ne marche pas ce libre
échange sauvage et cette mondialisation
qui éradique toute agriculture et bien
la france risquent un jour il n'ya plus
que 2 5% de paysans en france sur la
population
nous risquons un jour de voir
disparaître la totalité de notre
agriculture authentique soit remplacé
par les usines et des fabricants de
malbouffe
est-ce qu'il ya quand même des
agriculteurs en heureux en france on en
rencontre quand même de temps en temps
plus en plus de plus en plus parce qu'il
ya de la part du consommateur de la part
de la population une prise de conscience
sur une qualité améliorée de notre
culture il ya une demande pour des
produits sains respecter l'environnement
l'agriculture biologique est en train de
faire des progrès même si elle n'est pas
la solution totale l'idée définitive ya
d'autres traditions et puis il ya des il
ya des paysans les agriculteurs qui
prennent à bras le corps leur destin
grâce à cette cette prise de conscience
du consommateur et ses agriculteurs qui
veulent sortir de là il ya aujourd'hui
une dynamique certaine avec des progrès
énormes ça c'est indéniable il faut les
encourager et les pouvoirs publics le
savent mais la grande masse des
consommateurs et la grande masse des
agriculteurs sont encore d'un système
économique qui est accablant qui est
catastrophique et qui à mon avis va se
va aboutir à des concentrations il ya
des zones désertiques total il y aura t
il en france pour me donner à manger
la france est même la première puissance
agricole en europe production estimée à
73 milliards d'euros en 2018 selon les
données de l'insee
l'allemagne n'est pas très loin derrière
et si extraordinaire parce que
l'allemagne qui était la grande
puissance industrielle qu'à participer à
l'éradication l'industrie française
nous avions encore cet avantage d'avoir
une agriculture florissante et
performante
et puis les allemands ont remis en
service les anciens kolkhozes et des
sovkhozes de l'allemagne de l'est
c'est à dire un productivisme outrancier
avec une production à échelle qui est
absolument démoniaque et aujourd'hui ses
usines à mal bouffe allemande inondé
pays européens et la france de produits
à bas coûts face auxquels les
agriculteurs français ne peuvent pas
lutter donc le la situation de
prédominance de la culture française est
en train de disparaître les allocations
européennes sont quand même allés le
plat plupart du temps aux plus riches
aux plus puissants et aux plus possédant
d'agriculture notamment les céréaliers
on commence aujourd'hui à répartir un
peu mieux et la réforme de la pac et
l'abandon des quotas laitiers on est
dans les mesures économiques et bien
fait que ce pays qui devait être
florissant et la culture françaises
devraient être à la france ce que
l'industrie est à l'allemagne c'est à
dire sa ressource de richesse sa
ressource de puissance à ressources de
prédominance et bien cet alignement sur
le sur le néo libéralisme financier
globalisés a ruiné nos agriculteurs est
en train d'éradiquer la culture français
est ce qu'aujourd'hui un agriculteur
français doit en vie
et un agriculteur britannique non non
parce que la situation est la même pour
tous les pays européens si c'était écrit
avec les brics alors que dans chaque
pays il ya des j'allais dire des
politiques je vous parle évidemment en
vue du bric citant le le futur agricole
le britannique le grec cité cas
évidemment rendre à apporter un souffle
nouveau aux agriculteurs anglais mais
les agriculteurs anglais avait déjà eu
conscience de tout ce qui est des
valeurs de la terre du patrimoine d'une
forme de tradition agricole que les
français avaient perdu et est évidemment
le bric site va épargner va éviter une
concurrence déloyale aux acteurs
britanniques qui vont rentrer dans un
marché concurrentiel normal mais en tout
cas
boris johnson protège ses paysans et en
angleterre on n'a pas le nombre de
suicides
on peut tout dire de l'angleterre on n'a
pas le nombre de suicides qu'il y ait en
france donc là il ya peut-être un poids
à faire et peut-être faut regarder la
situation en face savoir qui dit la
vérité et qui ment et qui envoie les qui
envoie les paysans à la corde c'est pas
voyez c'est pas ceux qu'on croit
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire quand vous
voyez ces images de politique déambuler
dans les salons de l'agriculture souvent
la veille des présidentielles en
l'occurrence des municipales 1 de tous
bords depuis des années c'est bien loin
de là mais en même temps bon non non
parce que c'est scandaleux c'est un
rituel traditionnel tous les chefs
d'état
fond cette visite j'allais dire qu'enfin
dans un programme quasi cas quasi
folklorique
on vient promettre des choses ont bien
rencontré ça se passe souvent mal à
françois hollande avait été très mal
accueillie on vient faire des promesses
à la classe paysanne et aux agriculteurs
qu'on ne tiendra pas on leur fait croire
que tout va pour le mieux et qu'on va
prendre les problèmes à bras le corps et
en fait à la fin du salon une fois que
c'est terminé
les agriculteurs rentrer dans leurs
campagnes vivent leur détresse vivre
leur misère ceux qui se sont mis
j'allais dire du fric plein les poches
qui sont les puissants les industriels
ressortent content parce que c'est une
kermesse c'est la kermesse de la finance
de la financiarisation de l'agriculture
et les vrais paysans restent avec leurs
problèmes et leur détresse c'est le
salon de l'hypocrisie de la fourberie
wallace elle a été finalement avec tous
les gouvernements david jacques chirac
beaucoup plus populaires peut-être que
que d'autres a longtemps ça vraiment été
la foire on la valise est la foire
agricole avec c'est la vitrine de la
culture française dans sa diversité
florissante la province et les campagnes
de monter vers la capitale où les
parisiens venaient voir l monde en petit
allait voir et puis un jour ça a basculé
de salon des campagnes françaises
c'est devenu le salon de la finance
agricole 7 est tombée aux mains des
financiers aux mains des banquiers aux
mains des industriels au mas des trusts
aux mains des lobbys aujourd'hui ce sont
les lobbys il faut écouter la démission
de nicolas hulot en août 2010 8 qui
explique comment les lobbys aux mines
mais la mamie sur ceux sur la production
agricole de ce pays pour comprendre
pourquoi aujourd'hui le salon de
l'agriculture c'est le salon des
fossoyeurs et pas le salon des
agriculteurs qui veulent vivre
aujourd'hui qu'elle est finalement
quelle serait la priorité les trois
mesures à prendre
notre consoeur karine lemarchand salue
d'ailleurs a lancé le grand débat sur
l'agriculture pour une durée de trois
mois
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire justement
sortir tout de suite la grille dur
française
d'une concurrence déloyale à laquelle
elle ne peut pas résister la protégée
relancer une production intérieure
respectueuse de l'environnement à un
certain prix
une éducation scolaire sur la façon de
consommer des grandes campagnes pour
expliquer aux consommateurs français
qu'il vaut mieux réduire les quantités
ce qui engendre une économie qui permet
de financer une qualité meilleure et de
repenser notre consommation en tout cas
protéger d'urgence les secteurs
agricoles les plus exposées à la
concurrence déloyale international faire
un protectionnisme intelligent mais pas
forcément français c'est à l'europe aux
producteurs pas la france et dire aux
agriculteurs qui font un très beau
métier faciliter leur installation
foncière parce que là aussi ça coûte
très cher et faire en sorte que la
grande distribution le plus le scandale
le plus bas le majeur de ce quinquennat
c'est la loi des états généraux de
l'alimentation la loi galim issues des
états généraux qui est un fiasco total
ou le président d'un public avait promis
que désormais ce sont les agriculteurs
qui fixerait leurs prix et que ces
tarifs ne leur serait pas imposé ni par
les industriels n'est pas les grands
distributeurs et jamais la concurrence
n'a été aussi sauvage jamais la grande
distribution n'a imposé autant ses prix
à la production et jamais on n'a eu
autant celui-ci donc la loi et galim
c'est une c'est une forfaiture c'est un
mensonge est aujourd'hui l'urgence est
de faire en sorte que la grande
distribution n'étrangle pas les
industriels qui eux mêmes sont tenus de
d'étrangler les agriculteurs c'était une
mesure simple et précise faut juste
avoir un peu de courage politique pour
la mettre en place merci beaucoup périco
légasse d'avoir été avec nos
journalistes critiques gastronomiques
merci à vous dans quelques instants
rester avec nous parlerons de la demande
d'extradition de julian assange vers les
états unis examinée par la justice
britannique et nous reviendrons sur la
visite officielle de donald trump en
inde président américain a été accueilli
en grande pompe
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
tiacoh politique n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent la haine en soi vient
de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
est ce que la chine et la nouvelle
superpuissance du sport tout est
réalisable à la mesure de l'ambition
dévorante de la chine
je pense que dans les années à venir ça
va être un rival important pour être
pour nos milieux sport mondial
l'ambition que ce que s'est donnée le
président jean ping s'est non seulement
d'avoir le plus grand nombre de
médailles mais d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de chinois qui pratiquent le
sport le football c'est sympathiquement
une des sports les plus connues dans le
monde et la chine veulent en faire
partie et va être un des meilleurs mais
aussi un petit peu comme en russie une
volonté de nationaliser un peu le sport
indirectement en obligeant les grands
patrons des grandes entreprises qui
appartiennent toutes au parti communiste
à investir ans parlait des plus grandes
fortunes chinoises sont tout
propriétaire d'un club de foot rancennes
l'intéressé de dettes d'abord donne
d'être reconnus d'être reconnu en tant
qu'expert est de faire en sorte que que
la chine soit reconnu comme un grand
pays
[Musique]
les blanchons les bébés phoques du
groenland naissent sur la banquise de la
mer blanche
tout au long du xxème siècle les bébés
phoques ont été chassés pour leur
fourrure blanche comme neige
depuis que la chasse aux phoques est
interdite en russie il n'y a que les
touristes qui viennent voir ces animaux
à l'état sauvage
mais ces petits seront ils toujours en
sécurité
[Musique]
le 16 juin 1941
nous avions notre bal de fin d'études
c'est là que la guerre a éclaté
les magasins étaient remplis tic tu
ailles énormément de bord d'une vente et
et le lendemain la ville était paralysée
d'un disparu
toutes les étagères étaient vides au
mois de novembre
ils ont bombardé les entrepôts m'a
d'ailleurs ils les ont bombardées au
point que tout a été mélangée à la terre
les gens mangeaient cette terre mélangée
au sucre qui s'y trouvaient j'ai goûté
mais c'était pas mangeable
cette nuit là il ya eu un bombardement
terrible et la maison où se trouvait la
bri a été entièrement détruite il
brouille buecher tous les gens étaient
ensevelies sous les décombres
personne ne s'en est sorti vivant
[Musique]
m
merci nous rejoindre en direct sur rt
france pour cette deuxième heure
d'émission tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce lundi est lé
premier jour du procès d'extradition de
julian assange au royaume uni les
risques cent soixante quinze années de
prison aux états unis
washington qui a accusé le fondateur de
wikileaks d'avoir mis en des sources en
danger en publiant une masse
d'informations classifiées
c'est un premier déplacement officiel en
inde pour donald trump un accueil
particulier réservé au président
américain avec un meeting géant aux
côtés de rana rendre à modiin escapade
au taj mahal
les deux hommes ont affiché une entente
très cordiale dans un contexte de vives
tensions commerciales entre les deux
pays
le monde doit se préparer à une
éventuelle pandémie de coronavirus
indique l' oms en france il n'y a plus
aucun malade hospitalisé pour ce bien us
alors qu'un sixième patient est mort en
italie
onze villes du nord sont placés en
quarantaine face aux dangers de la
propagation des responsables politiques
de droite et d'extrême droite réclame
des contrôles aux frontières françaises
vraiment une solution l'europe doit être
plutôt apporter une réponse commune ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face à
21h30
[Musique]
vu la naissance sera-t-il extradé vers
les états unis le fondateur de wikileaks
comparer en ce moment devant la justice
britannique londres doit décider de
donner suite ou non à la demande
américaine de l'extrader l'occasion pour
le père de julian assange leif effectué
le rédacteur en chef de wikileaks de
s'exprimer ce dernier dénonce une
propagande tactique contre wikileaks
après 10 ans d'enquêté
dix ans l'afer a été abandonné les
charges ont été abandonnées
ils étaient quatre procureurs vous avez
bien vu tout cela et il n'a fallu que
huit ans pour mettre un homme sur la
lune
dix ans le dernier élément reste
l'accusation contre julian d'avoir aidé
chelsea manning à son procès celle ci a
parlé de sa motivation et de sa décision
délibérée de se tourner vers julien et
wikileaks et de se mettre en contact
avec lui afin de laisser fuiter ces
documents préoccupant abordant des
injustices et des crimes de guerre
il n'y a rien de nouveau rien que nous
n'avons pas déjà entendu en disant cette
accusation de faire du mal en exposant
le crime de guerre
le mal fait en irak en afghanistan
c'est une allégation qui ne tenait pas
la route il ya dix ans et qui ne tient
certainement pas la route aujourd'hui et
c'est une tactique de propagande pour
détourner l'attention sur le fait que
wikileaks avait exposé des crimes des
crimes de guerre à paris également lé
soutien à julian assange sont mobilisés
écouter on est en train de faire la
chasse aux lanceurs dalet notre nos
démocraties sont grands noms danger on
ne peut pas être extradé pour si c'est
une question politique
bien sûr que c'est politique même la
reine d'angleterre
il y a quelques jours l'a dit qu'elle
n'allait pas répondre sur cette question
voilà ce qui arrive si si on est
courageux et qu'on est un peu pas très
diplomatique ban ont fini au trou c'est
pas simplement le cadre d'un pauvre type
qui a été torturée dupuis kw à 7 8 ans
maintenant
bcc c'est un cadeau pour tout le monde
c'est à dire s'ils peuvent enfermé par
les états unis s'est même pas leur
propre pays
s'ils peuvent bois à on n'aime pas ce
type
eh ben on va les enfermer parce que
c'est aux causes des états unis que tout
ça c'est monté et ben il peut le faire à
n'importe qui et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis oxford au
royaume uni avec nike l'arc journaliste
indépendant c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soit
[Musique]
bonsoir n'éclate merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france déjà première
question vous êtes au royaume uni est ce
que c'est un procès qui est
particulièrement suivi sur place qui
fait couler beaucoup d'encre qui est
attendu par les britanniques pendant
soit bonsoir je ne dirais pas qu'il
s'agit d'une information majeure mais
cela sera peut-être demain aujourd'hui
beaucoup de joueurs vous parler mais ce
n'était pas le grand titre en fait cela
a été éclipsé par ce qui s'est passé par
exemple avec la ferrari tonnes larry
dunn était un jeune britannique de 19
ans qui a été tué sur sa motocyclette en
octobre ils étaient tués par une femme
america lui à proximité d'une base
aérienne
cette dame est retourné aux états unis
et les états unis ont refusé de
l'extrader
afin qu'ils à quelle heure assister au
procès on prétend qu'elle conduisait du
mauvais côté de la route
si c'est une marie travaillé pour la cia
et ils ont utilisé leur immunité
diplomatique
alors même qu'il ne faisait pas tu ne
figurait pas sur la liste des diplomates
une beaucoup de britanniques disais
pourquoi d'extrader riou julien assange
c'est un citoyen australien n'oublions
pas il n'est pas américain
pourquoi devrions-nous à l'extrader vers
les thèses mieux alors que les états
unis refusent d'extrader leurs citoyens
cette femme qui est lié à la mort d'un
jeune britannique parce qu'elle
conduisait ce couple présume qu'ils ont
écouté de la route
et pourtant les états unis
high stakes donc les personnes pensent
que les etats-unis se croit capable de
pouvoir exiger que tout le monde soit
extradé vers eux-mêmes vers leur jeu
d'action même s'il s'agit pas
l'américain donc que pour beaucoup de
britanniques
c'est un sujet de réflexion n'empêche
oui bien plus qu'il ne l'aurait fait
auparavant et certains disent que julian
assange devrait pas être extradé avant
la fin de la sphère de ce jeune homme
alors il n'empêche ce parallèle est
peut-être intéressant mais enfin un
procès sur les droits c'est sur les
faits chaque histoire évidemment est
différente
est ce que le risque que tombent craint
évidemment c est ce que ce procès selon
vous sera forcément politique où les
juges britanniques assez réputés sains
d'ailleurs pour leurs compétences vont
être finalement assez serein assez
indépendant est assez forts dans leur
tête pour éviter de tomber dans ce
travers
on imagine que les pressions sont
forcément très forte sur eux la pression
est très forte
comment le savons nous comment ça montre
que c'est politique c'est très simple il
suffisait hier d'examiner les emails qui
est en fuite et des emails des autorités
britanniques à aux autorités suédoises
julian assange a été accusé d'agression
sexuelle à ce que le procureur
britannique a envoyé un e mail teaser ne
nous est pas ne prenez pas peur à 100
des soins s'agissant d'attaqué jeunesse
en jeu ont su est pourquoi les autorités
britanniques s'intéresserait presque
aucun cas suédois il en australien qui
m'ont fait face à des accusations de
crimes sexuels
julien assange avait travaillé dans
d'autres domaines tels que les btp par
exemple
il ne pourrait imaginer que les
britanniques s'y intéressent mais ils
ont envoyé saison elle verra sonde pour
tous et la suède a attaqué julien
assange et à mener le procès donc cela
montre qu'il s'agit d'une affaire
politique et qu'il ya beaucoup de
pression sur les juges et sur le milieu
judiciaire système judiciaire l'exercice
n'exerce pas dans le vide
c'est un cas très typique
julian assange le montre exposé ce qui
se passe dans les coulisses il a dévoilé
des crimes de guerre les perpétrateurs
de ces crimes et ceux qui ont essayé de
les ouvrir
quel à s'assurer qu'il ne sera jamais le
béret donc effectivement il ya d'énormes
pressions sur les juges et le milieu
judiciaire
il faut qu'ils extra de julien saint
jean aux états unis les états unis
aujourd'hui qui accuse julian assange
d'avoir mis en danger à des sources en
révélant plusieurs informations
qu'est ce que répondait les défenseurs
justement du fondateur de wikileaks à
ces accusations
ils ont demandé plus de détails il ils
ont eu raison
aujourd'hui c'est le premier jour de
l'audience d'extradition l'avocat
commence déjà à très fort il explique
qu'il ne s'agit pas de wikileaks de la
fuite de ces documents sur la crim sur
la guerre d'irak ou d'afghanistan
le problème c'est qu'il est mis il avait
de ces gens en danger mais ils n'ont pas
vraiment donné de nom les avocats de
julian assange qui nous avons besoin de
plus de détails comment pouvez vous
affirmer cela sans le prouver
quelle vie ont été mises à risque dites
nous la vérité car tout ce qu'il a fait
tout ce que wikileaks affaire celle à
publier des documents qui sont vrais et
n'ont rien inventé et n'ont pas menti
ils ont publié des dossiers des câbles
informatiques des câbles diplomatiques
des vidéos de ce qui s'est vraiment
passé donc s'agissant de qui met la
vidéo qui en danger il est relativement
clair que les guerres qui ont été
déclarés et ensuite révélés par
wikileaks était absurde à l'époque et
aujourd'hui nous vous voyons la personne
qui a montré il dévoilait ses crimes de
guerre accusés devant les tribunaux et
non pas les personnes qui ont causé ces
guerres lors de la guerre d'irak à
millions de personnes sont mortes et
pourtant cette invasion d'irak étaient
illégales en matière de droit
international que les personnes qui ont
prévenu cette guerre et qu'ils ont mais
on ne sont pas accusés
c'est la personne qui a révélé ces
crimes de guerre qui est accusé donc ce
sont les clubs les personnes qui
poursuivre julian assange qui met sa vie
en danger
une dernière question et claque
aujourd'hui f que c'est exact de dire
finalement que de condamner je vienne
assange à l'extradition aux etats-unis
ces deux clairement le condamné à la
prison à vie
oui je pense que c'est tout à fait le
cas il pourrait effectivement être le
condamné est théoriquement à 175 années
de prison il ne veut pas en sortir en
vie c'est évident le problème c'est que
s'il était libéré alors wikileaks
continuerait et ils continueraient à
publier à exposer des crimes si on ne
l'aiment pas des guerres c'est le gala
alors on a une raison de s'inquiéter de
wikileaks sa seule chance s'il est
extradé aux états unis serait peut-être
de promettre qu'il arrêterait son
travail pour lucky luke c'est qu'il ne
s'occuperait plus de politique et qu'il
retournerait
en australie avec sa famille qu'il
arrêterait ses actions polémique
cela serait peut-être le seul moyen de
garantir sa libération s'il était
extradé
mais il resterait le problème du point
de vue des etats-unis il va il à faire
un exemple de ce cas car s'il se montre
clément envers julien assange alors cela
serait-il assez dissuasif pour les
personnes qui veulent suivre son exemple
la chance une libération est très basse
et des temps de julian assange serait
prêt à trouver un accord je pense que
s'il était extradé il ne quitterait pas
la prison à vie
je remercie beaucoup avec l'arcade avoir
été avec nos journalistes indépendants
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir merci à
vous ouverture aujourd'hui à genève de
la 43ème session du conseil des droits
de l'homme le ministre français des
affaires étrangères jean yves le drian
doit officiellement présenter la
candidature de la france cette
institution composé de 47 états pour un
mandat de trois ans une initiative
française est contestée par le collectif
des familles unies il représente une
centaine de familles françaises dont les
proches sont partis en syrie ou en irak
faire le djihad l ouverture de laisser
sur annuel le secrétaire général des
nations unies antonio goûter rsa lancé
un cri d'alarmé
je suis venu au conseil des droits de
l'homme le pivot du dialogue et de la
coopération internationale pour faire
progresser tous les droits de l'homme
pour lancer un appel à l'action et j'ai
décidé de le faire maintenant
en cette année du 75e anniversaire des
nations unies en raison de la place
centrale qu'occupe les droits de l'homme
dans toutes les activités de l'onu est
parce que les droits de l'homme sont
menacés je vous le disais la france est
donc accusée par le collectif des
familles unies de violer la convention
des droits de l'enfant alors quelle est
la position du gouvernement français
face au rapatriement des djihadistes le
point avec david khalifa en 2019
ils étaient plus de six mille cinq cents
enfants de djihadistes
étrangers réunis ici dans ce scandale au
nord de la syrie où les conditions de
vie sont déplorables des familles
entières et des français également une
situation humanitaire qui alerte la
communauté internationale la france est
pointée du doigt par la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme dans sa gestion des
rapatriements de ces djihadistes
c'est le cas pour ces onze français
capturés en syrie et condamné à mort en
irak en 2019 au nom des valeurs de notre
république et du respect des droits
fondamentaux
la commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme demandent au
gouvernement d'organiser sans tarder le
retour de ses ressortissants pour être
jugé si la france ne les rapatrie pas
elle bafoue ses valeurs et engagements
internationaux puisque l'hexagone est
contre la peine de mort pour le
gouvernement la situation de ses
djihadistes it une poudrière
plusieurs sondages récents ayant montré
l'hostilité de l'opinion au rapatriement
de djihadistes pourtant le mois dernier
nicole belloubet avait pour la première
fois émis l'hypothèse de la possibilité
de juger en france les ressortissants
détenus par les kurdes de syrie
jusqu'aux récentes évolutions nous
pensions à la possibilité de mettre en
place avec d'autres états européens un
tribunal mixte en irak pour juger les
djihadistes étrangers que leur pays ne
veulent pas reprendre un tribunal que
nous aurions appuyé mais la donne a
changé
dans ce cas là il n'est plus possible de
les juger sur place
je ne vois pas d'autre solution que de
rapatrier ces gens en france tous
combattants terroristes qui seraient
rapatriés serait judiciariser comme nous
l'avons toujours fait
les forces kurdes de syrie de leur côté
ont réitéré ce dimanche leur besoin
d'une aide internationale juridique pour
juger sur place les milliers de
djihadistes de dèche
mais depuis la déclaration de la
ministre de la justice
aucune avancée majeure n'a eu lieu et
plusieurs collectifs sont montés au
créneau pour dénoncer l'inaction du
gouvernement face à cette situation
humanitaire désastreuse
ce n'est pas seulement le jugement de
ces djihadistes qui est remis en cause
mais également la situation des enfants
pour m bailly avocat d'une dizaine de
familles qui cherchent à faire revenir
en france leurs enfants il est certain
que le gouvernement ne fait preuve
d'aucune bonne volonté si on
on arrive finalement à une politique au
cas par cas c'est aussi parce que
l'opinion publique est aujourd'hui
encore hostile au rapatriement de ces
tout petits on le comprend on comprend
cette peur légitime mais il nous semble
nous avocats saisis par les grands
parents il nous semble que ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas la hauteur d'un pays comme
la france
ce n'est pas la hauteur de notre
patrimoine juridique de laisser des
enfants dans des camps dans lesquels ils
meurent de malnutrition dans les camps
une meurent de maladies et les chiffres
parlent d'eux mêmes les conditions de
vie particulièrement difficiles ont
entraîné la mort de plus de 517
personnes donc 371 enfants en 2019 dans
le camp d'alcool depuis septembre
dernier la commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme
exhortent l'état français à gien tapis
rouge pour donald trump ans dans le
président américain est arrivé ce matin
pour une visite d'état de deux jours au
programme un meeting géant au côté du
premier ministre indien on a maudit
donald trump s'envolera ensuite vers new
delhi les deux pays sont engagés dans un
bras de fer commercial depuis l'année
dernière et deux hommes ont affiché à
l'avancé de leurs relations avec de
futurs accords commerciaux
oui nous sommes aux première étape des
discussions en vue d'un incroyable
accord commercial visant à réduire les
barrières des investissements entre les
etats-unis et l'inde et je suis heureux
d'annoncer que demain nos représentants
signeront un accord pour la vente de
plus de 3 milliards de dollars
d'hélicoptères militaires et d'autres
équipements à la pointe de la
technologie aux forces armées indiennes
je me souviens lorsque je suis allé à
washington la première fois que j'ai
rencontré le président trump il m'avait
dit que l'inde avait un véritable ami à
la maison blanche
le président trump a toujours montré son
amour particulier pour l'inde
que ce soit dans les secteurs de la
défense de l'énergie de la santé ou des
technologies de l'information dans tous
les secteurs
nos relations se renforce et pour en
parler nous sommes avec claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison alors pour soirée pour
bien qu'on comprenne pourquoi l'inde et
il a un pays si important pour les
etats-unis et pour les etats-unis l'inde
est un enjeu fondamental puisque l'inde
est la clé de la stratégie radeau
pacifique des états unis c'est à dire
d'une stratégie qui va de l'océan indien
à l'océan pacifique est évidemment
l'inde occupe la position clé il s'agit
en fait de contenir l'influencé chinoise
croissante dans toute l'asie pacifique
dans toute cette zone est pour cela
l'inde est évidemment le pays qui de
l'autre côté de l'himalaya peut faire
progressivement équilibre à la chine
alors il ya aussi naturellement le fait
que l'inde est devenue la cinquième
économie du monde
ce qui est tout à fait considérable elle
a dépassé la dernière la france et la
grande bretagne
elle est encore assez loin mais pas
tellement de l'allemagne au plus loin du
japon
naturellement très loin de la chine et
les états unis mais enfin la cinquième
puissance économique ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'elle a sur ces voies
d'approvisionnement qu'elles assurent sa
sécurité qu'elle constitue des forces
navales des forces de défense alors elle
a évidemment constitué des forces de
dissuasion nucléaire puisque l'inde
possède l'armé nucléaire pour tenir en
respect ses voisins le rival chinois he
et le pakistan assez hostile à cause de
la sphère du cachemire et puis elle
constitue aussi en est
et des forces conventionnelles et des
forces navales de façon à assurer sa
sécurité comme l'asse peut l'industrie
d'armement qui soit compétitive elle
achète beaucoup d'armement à l'étranger
et tous les grands pays fournisseurs
d'armement sont évidemment en
concurrence pour lui fournir sésame le
premier fournisseur étant de loin le
fournisseur traditionnel c'est la russie
alors pourquoi donald trump et le
premier ministre on l'a vu maudissent
semble si bien s'entendre alors qu'on
sait que le contexte concurrentiel et
quand même tendu vers entre les deux
pays
oui je crois que d'abord il ya un
facteur psychologique c'est à dire que
les deux hommes fonctionne un peu de la
même manière il considère que les
relations entre les leaders sont tout à
fait fondamentale est en effet il ya une
alchimie qui semble exister entre les
deux hommes tous les deux sont assez
autoritaire d'ailleurs dans la façon de
fonctionner et qui parfois les
accommodements avec les procédures
démocratiques
alors monsieur trump avait emmené
monsieur maudit à houston au mois de
septembre pour parler devant de rendre
devant à une assemblée considérable d'en
installer houston stade dans lequel il y
avait beaucoup d'américains d'origine
indienne qui constitue un électorat
peut-être marginal mais quand même un
électorat important pour monsieur trump
est là et bien monsieur maudit lui a
rendu la pareille mais évidemment aux
dimensions de l'inde avec plus de cent
mille personnes dans un stade tout neuf
qui vient d'être terminé et on a vu dans
tous les symboles que maudit aujourd'hui
faisait le maximum en effet pour
démontrer pour mettre en scène cette
familiarité cette amitié avec le
président américain
demain on passera aux choses sérieuses à
delhi en parlant économie alors dans ce
bon contexte de belle entente cordiale
est-ce que donald trump et ils se
permettent d'exprimer quelques réserves
sur la politique nationaliste de premier
ministre vers l'or il ya six mois
lorsque
le gouvernement indien un peu par
surprise en lait cru du mois d'août
avait décidé de changer la situation
constitutionnelle du cachemire qui est
un territoire disputé entre le pakistan
un petit peu la chine et surtout et
l'inde
eh bien n'écoutant que son bon coeur le
président américain avait dit mais
peut-être que sa vie pourrait faire une
médiation alors l'inde effectivement ces
cas-là il surtout pas c'est un sujet
purement bilatérale laissez nous parlait
en tant que de besoin avec le pakistan
surtout ne vous mêlez pas de ça je crois
que le président trump a bien compris la
leçon
c'est une position indienne à ses
anciennes d'ailleurs traditionnelle et
je ne pense pas qu'il revienne sur ce
sujet cela dit la situation au cachemire
et sérieuse parce que les libertés ont
été supprimés et le nouveau stade du
fait du cachemire est d'ailleurs du
ladakh puisqu'on a coupé en deux
l'ancien cachemire indien des
territoires de l'union directement
administrée par un gouverneur nommé par
le par le parent le président par le
premier ministre maudit et puis il ya eu
les loirs plus récentes sur la
nationalité qui prévoit qui permettent à
des réfugiés politiques venant des pays
voisins qui sont des pays généralement à
majorité
l'islamic de d'avoir la nationalité
indienne
mais justement sauf s'ils sont de
nassiet de confession islamique et par
conséquent la plupart des gens et ont vu
une discrimination est évidemment il ya
eu des mouvements en plusieurs
universités indiennes dans plusieurs
villes indiennes
il est probable que
le président américain sera obligée des
différents légion mais de façon je crois
assez assez assez discrète est assez
légère car ce n'est pas l'objectif de sa
visite
l'objectif de ces visites c'est de
rééquilibrer les échanges entre l'inde
et les états unis
les échanges sont à peu près 150
milliards de dollars l'inde a un
excédent d'environ 23 milliards de
dollars
et bien comme il l'a fait avec la chine
le président américain a taxé à 25%
l'acier indien a taxé à 10% l'aluminium
à deera et se prépare à faire d'autres
mesures du même genre il a aussi retiré
l'inde du bénéfice des préférences
généralisées qui s'appliquait pour un
certain nombre de pays en développement
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
pour votre analyse rester avec nous dans
quelques instants notre débat sur le
coronavirus ce soir alors que l'italie
est touché de plein fouet avec un
sixième patients décédés et 11 villes du
nord placé en quarantaine la france
doit-elle contrôler ses frontières comme
le suggèrent certains à face à la
propagation du virus on en débattra avec
à nos invités
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi cette merde
puis l'année dernière la quantité de
drogue saisie a augmenté d'environ 490
euros pour ce rpg à palencia drogue
et on m'a arrêté en pensant que j'étais
membre d'un gang
j'étais suspecté de 10 ici la plupart de
femmes que rage de très longues peines
de prison
il tente un milieu va donc nous avons
inventé ce concours pour le remonter un
peu le moral je vais certes indiqué je
suis déterminé à remporter le titre miss
talent avéré c'est le sentiment que vous
avez eue vous aussi ce besoin
d'autonomie
oui complètement a besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes qui poussent le fait de
vivre avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
communiste comme une machine un
organisme pour fait partie de cet
organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps qu'on vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres mais je pense que
ces gens de projets qui se fait pas tout
seul dans son coin on est dans un truc
vraiment de coopération de partage de
partage
[Musique]
loïc et geoffroy deux frères animé par
leur passion pour l'eau ont décidé
d'emprunter les routes de la soie sur
les traces des premiers échanges entre
les civilisations
en quatre mois de la chine à paris et
parcours sur leur side car plus de 15000
kilomètres à travers l'asie centrale et
l'asie mineure pour revivre l'évolution
du commerce mondial et son impact sur la
ressource en eau la société afghane ne
permet pas aux femmes d'être libres
comme les hommes les hommes peuvent
faire ce qu'ils veulent mais pas les
femmes
[Musique]
nous avons encore besoin d'un garçon en
tout cas j'ai sept filles et pas de fils
[Musique]
en fait seules les filles qui viennent
chez nous et qui joue avec elles savent
que c'est une fille dehors quand elle
joue avec une balle
personne ne s'en rend compte que c'est
une fille et tout le monde croit que
c'est un garçon
[Musique]
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france merci de nous rejoindre un
l'inquiétude mondial donc faso
coronavirus 150 nouveaux décès
enregistrés en chine aujourd'hui le pays
n'avait pas signalé au temps mort depuis
11 jours près de 2600 personnes au total
ont perdu la vie depuis elle à fin
décembre mais on note un déclin tout de
même rassurant dans la propagation de la
maladie
ailleurs dans le monde la corée du sud
est désormais le plus grand foyer de
l'épidémie avec cette mort et 763
personnes contaminées puis vient l'iran
où le virus a fait 12 morts selon un
dernier bilan officiel en tout cas en
italie le virus a fait un septième mort
et la situation est préoccupante dans le
nord du pays confronté à une hausse des
cas de contamination l'europe invite les
états membres à se coordonner
mais à ne pas paniquer alors que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
elles tirent la sonnette d'alarmé
demande au monde se préparer à une
éventuelle pandémie du virus les détails
et françois tisci beach
ne pas céder à la panique c'est ce qu'a
déclaré la commission européenne lors
d'une conférence de presse devant
l'explosion de k2 coronavirus en italie
bruxelles a donc décidé de lancer l'
alerte tout en appelant au calme et à
l'unité
compte tenu de cette situation je
voudrais dire aujourd'hui que nous
allons faire tout notre possible pour
aider les états membres à faire face à
la situation
nous devons bien sûr prendre cette
situation très au sérieux mais nous ne
devons pas céder à la panique et plus
important encore à la désinformation
nous devons être très unie dans notre
réponse cohérente et coordonnée avec le
développement du virus sur le continent
c'est aussi la question de la libre
circulation des personnes au sein de
l'espace schengen qui est posée pour
l'instant la commission n'entend pas
faire de recommandations sur la
fermeture éventuelle des frontières
sujets qui relèvent de la prérogative
des états membres nous pensons que les
mesures doivent être en premier lieu
fondée sur une évaluation crédible des
risques et des preuves scientifiques
deuxièmement les mesures doivent être
proportionnées et troisièmement elle
doit être prise en coordination avec
d'autres nous devrions agir en tant
qu'union et non individuellement le code
des frontières schengen permet de
réintroduire temporairement les
contrôles aux frontières
mais une telle mesure comme je les dis
je dois être prise compte tenu des
conditions que je vais le mentionner
l'italie a d'ailleurs proposé une
réunion des ministres de la santé des
pays frontaliers de la péninsule ce
mardi après midi pour déterminer des
lignes d'action commune et un contrôle
aux frontières pourraient être rétablis
il faut dire que l'inquiétude gagne les
villes proches de la frontière italienne
en france la préfecture des
alpes-maritimes a annoncé ce lundi après
midi la mise en place d'une cellule de
vigilance quotidienne et le renforcement
du dispositif sanitaire des mesures de
précaution pour les personnes revenant
du nord de l'italie seront également
prises dans tout l'hexagone alors que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
demande au monde de se préparer à une
éventuelle pandémie
et face aux dangers de la propagation
des responsables politiques de droite et
d'extrême droite réclame des contrôles
aux frontières françaises est ce
vraiment une solution l'europe doit-elle
apporter une réponse commune quelles
sont les mesures préconisées c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir et
pour en débattre nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec philippe muray économistes
souverainiste bonsoir philippe muray
race écouter bonsoir patrick mennucci
conseiller municipal de marseille
bonsoir et merci d'être là vous aussi
patrick mennucci relâche m'adresse aux
responsables politiques est ce que c'est
le cauchemar de tout responsable
politique une épidémie qui menace son
pays comme ça je sens effectivement
cette cette inquiétude et je crois que
les pouvoirs publics sont mobilisés il
me semble que dans la situation dans
laquelle on est il faut éviter les cocos
tisme les fausses nouvelles il faut être
vraiment
faire confiance à la science et en même
temps il faut prendre les mesures j'ai
données que vous disiez que des des
dirigeants de droite ou l'extrême droite
demandé la fermeture affaires où des
contrôles à la frontière italienne
honnêtement ça ne paraît pas être sujets
de désaccord droite gauche paraît pas
être une mesure qui ne doit pas
cependant si elle ne sait s'il est
nécessaire de la pente mais il faut le
faire
il me semble qu'il faut éviter comme
j'ai entendu ce matin madame buzet à
france inter de quasiment accusé anne
hidalgo ne pas avoir préparé la sq ont
peu savoureux éviter parler des
municipales ici si on veut pas voir le
csa sur le dos non mais je parlais de la
ministre
les nations qui ont parlé de la ministre
nous sommes quand même que ceux qui
puisque vous poser l'acte et d'acier
vous doivent faire les hommes et les
femmes politiques dans cette
circonstance et gardé beaucoup de calme
et éviter de me faire des sujets de
polémique politicienne
il me semble que c'est ça qui doit être
la base de toute réflexion sur le sujet
dans ce cas c'est vrai que c'était plus
à droite ont demandé ce contrôle des
frontières on va justement regarder ce
qu'on pensait marine le pen et eric
ciotti voilà de tous cas ce matin
justement aujourd'hui ou demain il
faudra peut-être des contrôles aux
frontières le gouvernement doit pouvoir
le prévoir et je préfère qu'il en fasse
plus haut trop que pas assez
là pour l'instant il n'en fait pas assez
notamment permettant les vols en
provenance de chine pour protéger les
français
j'ai écrit au premier ministre pour lui
demander un plan d'urgence et des
contrôles renforcés à la frontière
italienne
les alpes-maritimes n'enregistre
influent quotidien de dizaines de
milliers de personnes avec l'italie 97 %
des médicaments sont actuellement
fabriqués à l'étranger et ne sont pas
soumis au contrôle européen
la propagation du coronavirus nous
appellent à une relocalisation des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques pour une
meilleure sécurité sanitaire des peuples
européens
saint-philippe merrer de même son
contrôle des frontières une ré corrie
rhétorique davantage voilà c'est nuit
par par la droite
alors moi je dirais que je sortirai de
la droite et de la gauche mais la
politique de bon sens elle serait qu'on
aille très vite je pense qu'on devrait
déjà contrôler les frontières
sérieusement avec l'italie et ça fait
bien longtemps qu'on devrait avoir
arrêté les voiles avec la chine ou alors
dévoile avec quarantaine
quand vous dites contre les frontières
ça veut dire quoi des contrôles de
température des trolls de température
voir effectivement les gens leur
expliquer puis surtout peut-être
restreindre aussi la circulation des
gens peut-être escande le touriste on
sait qu'il ya des touristes
encore qu'ils se baladent coréen corée
du sud sont en nous des touristes
chinois aussi qui se baladent et ça
c'est pas simple parce que si on se
rappelle comment pourquoi cette épidémie
a échappé l'état chinois
on revient en arrière autour du 15
janvier en fait le laitage l'état de
chinois a mis trop de temps à fermer la
frontière avec one est à dire on confine
one et à ce moment là il ya cinq
millions de personnes de one la zone
contaminée qui sont partis et qui ont
contaminé toute la chine est maintenant
qu'ils sont en train de contaminer le
monde entier donc on voit qu'il faut des
décisions très rapide très clair très
ferme
il ne pas laisser le temps justement par
exemple des italiens du nord qui a envie
de se déplacer ils vont se déplacer plus
vite ici avec un risque de porter le
virus etc
ces attentions c'est un moment qui va
être probablement qu'il va pas durer
très longtemps mais il faut prendre des
mesures parce que le but est d'épargner
des vies et d'épargné 7 propre et en
ayant ce en contrôlant nos frontières on
aide aussi les autres pays il faut que
les payer retrouve un petit peu de
sécurité à ce niveau là pour que le
virus se transmette pas d'un pays à
l'autre n'importe comment
je ne devais les merveilleux le début de
l'intervention de marine le pen mots me
choque pas je suis assez d'accord et se
dirigent ciotti parce qu'eric ciotti
faut bien écouter ce qu'il dit il dit
pas fermeture des frontières et des
contrôles
on peut avoir un contrôle de température
très fraîche si c'est nécessaire et si
les évaluations au monde que c'est ça
qu'il faut le faire et mais il faut pas
oublier quand même par l'allemande que
les italiens ont pris des mesures
puisqu'il ya onze kong
du nord de l'italie où les jeunes sont
confinés où donne théoriquement ils
peuvent pas se retrouver vous avez
regardé motifs j'ai pas regardé ce drame
de france 2 si garder le nôtre est alors
les journalistes non alors il disait
effectivement sur france 2 c'est
théoriquement confiné sauf que les
journalistes ont été envoyés ils sont
passés tout tranquillement le dimanche
soir dans la zone
effectivement les gens restés chez eux
mais c'était pas du tout confiné et tout
le monde pourrait rentrer et sortir je
vends des mollahs le moins moi je mange
pas choqué par un contrôle à la
frontière et je veux dire que dans ma
vie personnelle
d'ailleurs j'ai excusez moi de parler de
ça j'ai été interpellé parce que mon
fils qui a 7 ans et qui est dans une
école là pas loin
marc a porté son cahier de
correspondance et dans lequel il ya une
mesure de la ville de paris qui dit donc
des services scolaires dans la ville de
paris anne hidalgo qui dit que ce qui
serait allé en chine
à bord on était en vacances ce qui
serait très riche chine en corée du sud
en iran en voile à singapour et dans les
deux régions italiennes en barbie
concernés il ya quatre mesures prises de
température les masques etc et surtout
une interdiction aux enfants de l'école
pendant 14 jours
il ya une espèce de 40 c'est sûr que
c'est quelque chose qu'il ya des lycéens
qui préparent le bac
est-ce que c'est pas tout pour les
enfants
alors là pourquoi que pour les ans mais
déjà c'est ça que je ne comprends bien
parce que déjà je pense que l'école dans
les bureaux on est ensemble ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a quitté les barbus
game où et comment de ces faits non moi
je comprends que je vaux je vois quand
même que des atomes de mesures zhenghua
après on peut se poser activement la
question des départs c'est sûr mais un
iphone qui seraient dans cette situation
qu'il serait donc déclarée à la ville de
paris
alessi tutrice et je pense qu'on a la
capacité de remonter aux parents de deux
mois la gelée je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de jeunes qui sont allés en vacances
c'est beaucoup de gens souhaitent pas
laisser ces jeunes derrière marquez qui
ont pris quelques jours l'italie du nord
et il faut que je crois que chacun
prenne aussi sur lui c'est une affaire
sérieuse mais je pense que plus on saura
dans la date dans la danse dans la
science dans la tranquillité et pas dans
l'agressivité pas dans la politique
politicienne plus haut comme un grand de
nos concitoyens qui vont être vision
sérieux et qu'il faut se plier peut-être
une certaine dose ça c'est clair mais
moi je pense à moi je serai beaucoup
plus alarmiste que vous inclus début je
suis inquiet par cette épidémie parce
que ce qu'on voit faim depuis le début
depuis début février
ce qu'on voit c'est que la chine a mis
toutes les mesures en place possible et
des mesures en qui liberté très forte
que peut prendre un régime quasi
dictature est déconfinement de one mais
d'autres régions sont confinés d'autres
villes beaucoup de villes les gens ne
sont pas les trahir et pendant quinze
jours il malgré tout le virus s'est
propagé de façon très rapide on voit
qu'en corée du sud la situation était
pas bonne mais pas si mauvaise que ça il
y a quatre cinq jours je crois qu'il y
avait 60 cas où quelque chose comme ça
et d'un coup
ça a démarré sur 600 cas et ce qui est
très clair et que cette épidémie c'est
qu'elle est
il vaut mieux l'arrêter tout de suite
avant qu'elles arrivent comme on l'a
fait jusqu'à comme ça s'est passé
jusqu'à maintenant plutôt que d'avoir un
certain nombre de malades est là que ça
devienne complètement irrémédiable ce
qu'elle est plus grave que la grippe
oui on a donné un consentement quand
même je veux dire donc le tableau msa 10
3% ont besoin de ces variants s'attaquer
immédiatement les poumons
le taux des personnes âgées
mais oui c'est jean luc chanteau mais on
a aussi les gens de 30 ans dao beaucoup
de médecins qui sont morts en chine
et puis attention parce qu'elles se
propagent à une telle vitesse que je ne
crois pas une seconde aux chiffres
chinois qui sont annoncés plus qu'un
tour c'est vrai nom en tant
qu'économiste alors je vous le dis
pourquoi en tant qu'économiste je
regarde souvent les statistiques
chinoises point sur l'économie mondiale
tous les deux mois les statistiques
chinoises ne sont ne sont évidemment on
ne peut pas vraiment leur faire
confiance
vous pouvez pas voir 6% de croissance
puis 5,9 8,5 8,1 exemple tous ces
chiffres sont lissés tous ces chiffres
sont travaillés et contient une
statistique qui commence à déraper
généralement la chine arrête de la
sortir et là très clairement je vais
vous dire moi ce que je pense de ce qui
passe en chine il ya beaucoup plus de
l'état continuer à monter par contre ils
ont un problème majeur économique
puisque la chute des ventes de voitures
ces 92 % à keur baax arrêts et
l'immobilier et je pense qu'ils font le
choix de se dire il faut bien quand même
qu'on produise un petit peu qu'on
produise la nourriture pour alimenter et
puis pour pas tuer complètement
l'économie et je pense qu il minore
légèrement les chiffres c'est une
possibilité
et c'est d'autres épidémiologistes ainsi
des épidémiologistes qui dit ça
probablement pour lâcher un peu de lest
et pourra voir l'économie qui repart un
peu parce que là le risque c'est d'avoir
des millions de faillite en chine et un
problème économique vraiment gravissime
sinon patrick mennucci vous vous
partagez cette suspicion qui peut
simuler les les pays où
les organisation totalitaire les
chiffres qu'il donne sont toujours
soumis à une étude c'est évident il n'y
a que dans les pays comme la france la
plupart du temps les choses sont réels
on dit en en temps je ne sais pas si
c'est vrai que il ya eu un contrôle de
l'épidémie en chine qui a été fait bon
si c'est le cas tant mieux mais aux
formes la question est ce que les
verrines le véritable danger aujourd'hui
c'est pas plutôt le moyen-orient
l'afrique ou alors là il est les
systèmes rico sont peut-être une
défectueux qu'un chine
et là on risque effectivement d'abord
démarre alors je trouve qu'une des
choses qui manquent loyers ont discuté
de la dangerosité et ccd vraie
explication là dessus pour l'instant on
entend très peu comme vous je regarde
les gens alertés au journal de france 2
et c'est vrai que je vois assez peu
d'explications sur qu'est ce que c'est
cette maladie en fait
et quelles sont les conséquences et ce
pc est ce qu'on peut en mourir quand on
est déjà atteint on a dit que pas un peu
déjà qu'ils seront généralement c'est
plutôt ça dure trois à six semaines on
le sait c'est à cette période là il ya à
peu près 15 % des malades qui se
retrouve avec une pneumonie
voilà ça c'est sévère et alors c'est
vexant son état alors qu'avec la grippe
a c'est plutôt 3% et 0 1%
non je parle qui se retrouve dans une
situation difficile alors c'est du moins
ce que c'est vrai que 2 % ça paraît pas
grand chose tout le monde est infecté en
france ça fera quand même un million de
morts dont vous passez c'est avec marine
le pen l'état ont fait passé qu'est ce
que pourrait faire état aujourd'hui moi
je partage pas l'avis de marine le pen
c'est ce que fait marine le pen c'est de
la politique
après on peut faire la politique et dire
des choses tom dwan pas ma question de
le contrôler les frontières ne me paraît
pas un acte et des desserts quelles
raisons moi je trouve qu'elle a raison
là dessus parce que les états unis
interdisent les vols de la chine depuis
le début février
et je trouve que ça aurait dû être fait
en france de la même manière hong kong
interdit les vols aussi vers l'est de la
chine où mais les gens en quarantaine
quand c'est des résidents
la corée du sud aussi mg nous je trouve
qu'on est des grands bisous nourrit un
laxisme
moi je trouve que halak 6 et c'est même
une trahison des français parce qu'on
met les français en danger
alors quand j'entends l'union européenne
qui dit faux en fait l'important c'est
de se coordonner
est ce qui pourrait arrêter une réunion
d'ailleurs ce soir un déni traiter avec
leur idéologie le bon sens c'est pas de
se coordonner ces des gens d'agir chacun
a son équivalent mais chacun avec nos
attendions un peu de chaleur à son
échelle chacun avec ses moyens
chacun avec sa géographie chaque avec
ses problèmes en se coordonnant pour la
gestion des frontières
c'est ça le principal d'éviter des morts
d'éviter que ça se propage
parce que la chance qu'on a de se sortir
ce virus qu'on en sait rien et c'est une
chance que je virus se transmette moins
bien au moins pendant les mois chauds
donc il faut qu'on contient de cette
épidémie jusqu'au mois d'avril parce que
la probable il y a une chance à ces
fortes face comme pour le sarce ce virus
soit beaucoup moins dangereux et
transmissible à ce moment là sinon c'est
quand même une pandémie au mondial et
quelque chose ne pas drôle du tout si
les bourses s'effondrent
s'il aura pris les sites 6 août la
sélection de miss qui parle mais alors
c'est vrai que la bourse de milan a fini
sur un plongeon 5 43%
la très étonnante galerie mais je veux
dire la bourse d'abord le monde souvent
on ne sait pas pourquoi mais là où c'est
pourquoi le dessin il ya une baisse de
la consommation
si vous avez fermé les jeunes chez eux
à part en italie et aux communes
apparemment une situation dont des
communes qui sont à 55 kilomètres de
milan nationale en bout la zone
industrielle d'arzew voilà le cadeau que
c'est tout à fait logique mais je
compris en bourse de paris aussi à
baisser parce que s'il ya une baisse des
relations commerciales avec la chine et
il y aura obligatoirement dans les deux
sens d'ailleurs et c'est d'ailleurs plus
les chinois sans doute qu'ils seront
impactés que nous et ça aura des
conséquences sur les entreprises
françaises
j'ai dernièrement sur l'europe bon je
connais le le système c'est toujours la
faute à l'europe externe connaît mais là
en l'occurrence sur ce sujet l'art et la
responsabilité est aux états il n'y a
pas de responsabilité européenne
la décision de fermer la frontière à la
partie d'affaires de 8 il faut pas le
faire alors eux ils disent qu'il faut un
discours donné vous ils disent qu'ils
ont raison je suis pas pour mais non
mais vous fermez une frontière vous
passez pas à suisse et vous revenez en
france les frontières de bruxelles si
vous fait d'accord l'union européenne a
dit la commission à peine dit je vais
vous faire un plan moi je pense que je
devrais y vont faire un plan moi je
connais l'ensemble des pays
c'est pas lui c'est pas forcément
effectivement leurs compétences est
libre mais n'empêche qu'ils se mêlent de
tout et viennent nous expliquerons
catoire mais les frontières pas de
panique etc
non parce qu'il faut arrêter je vais
vous imaginez que me diriger à venir
dans la télévision et 10 les gars il
faut attendre panique ex nord par
conséquent la vérité ou être à
l'équilibré la vérité vont jusqu alors
je m appelle uci c'est difficile d'être
responsables politiques
cette espèce de deux lignes droites les
bris l'entrejeu on n'a pas paniqué et ne
doit sous-estimer
j'ai résolu faisait justement remarquer
que je sais qu'on met l'europe à toutes
les sauces je sais que l'europe est
responsable de tout il ya même une
technique qui consiste à mettre
tellement de responsabilités sur
l'europe qu'on en exonère nos dirigeants
de leur propre responsable
le fonds un voilà non mais très souvent
on y avait le c'est pas la faute du
président un pic prévu sa faute de
l'europe
or là disons non français puisqu'on est
en train d'en discuter les mesures qui
peuvent être prises et celles que vous
réclamez les mesures de sûreté de
contrôle extra ce sont des mesures qui
émaneront du ministre de la santé du lys
d'intérieur du produit plaisir d'un
public
c'est notre responsabilité c'est
responsabilité de la france donc il vaut
mieux le savoir au début de cette
affaire-là
plutôt que de laisser penser que
l'europe a du corps alors à faire en
train de dire monsieur mais non je le
dis qu'elle prépare un plan elle
conseille non mais je me perds la vérité
parce que le s quel domaine pression
elvin pression pour dire coordonnées
vous ne faites etc
il faut fermer ce soit ce soir
effectivement il ya trois wilayas ils
viennent réunion des ministres pour
trouver ma démission comme au lieu
d'être à bruxelles en train de se réunit
à trouver une solution commune
ils feraient bien d'être dans leur pays
pour travailler ils n'ont pas besoin de
dix ans pour se coordonner
c'est à chacun de prendre son habilité à
ses deux fils non c'est pas de la
démocratie c'est à dire sinon on a des
gens qui ne savent que vous avez vous
êtes très bien qu'on peut avoir déjà à
bruxelles de discuter d'autres à paris
on va travailler pour nourrir la
conversation va écouter l'avis du
médecin général 15 et qui étaient avec
nous on dirait que tout à l'heure pour
lui ces mesures de contrôles aux
frontières ont un intérêt politique
davantage la gestuelle mans on est
encore dans une phase en france on peut
isoler les patients la fenêtre de tir
elle va être relativement courte parce
que on voit bien qu'en italie ils sont à
plus de 200 cas plus on a des cas qui se
multiplient plus l'enjeu n'est plus
finalement de les y
les mets vraiment de les traiter et
voyez bien ici on a plusieurs centaines
de patients ça va être compliqué de les
isoler on n'imagine pas pour la grippe
par exemple isolé tout le monde donc
cette mesure de contrôle des frontières
voire de fermeture des frontières je
pense pas qu'en france on puisse fermer
les frontières mais elle aura un côté
symbolique qui serait peut-être pas
inutile ce contrôle de température ne
serait ce que pour rassurer les gens
mais on est bien d'accord que sur le
plan médical c'est pas ça qui empêchera
la diffusion du virus ce virus il est
très contagieux on le voit en italie on
sait même pas quel est le patient zéro
en télé le patient source ce virus il
est il a été transporté véhicules et de
chine
et on voit bien que ça paraît
extrêmement difficile de maintenir une
situation hermétique en france avec zéro
cas sur le territoire
la passion 0 continue à débattre bon pas
rassurant quand même le docteur qui
recèle qui pourtant était assez
rassurant il ya deux semaines enfin il
change avant mais je crois qu'il dit la
vérité est bien là la fermeture des
frontières vont où le contrôle de la
dette de la température ça sûrement un
effet qui montre à la population qui a
une prise en compte de cette affaire qui
appelle chacun un peu responsable avait
laissé entendre plus coincé à lyon toute
la journée
la dame chinoise qui arrivait dans un
commissariat aujourd'hui qui plus est on
a fermé commissariat il se trouvait
qu'elle avait rien n'a été juste
chinoise et insulté moi j'envoie d'aider
damas la pharmacie acheter des masques
parce qu'elles ont une une philippine à
la maison je laime tenu de mes oreilles
donc des abris on n'a pas fini d'en
entendre beau mais je crois qu'il faut
tout simplement en garde notamment je
pense que c'est le rôle les hommes
politiques et les femmes politiques il
faut à la fois à présent complètement la
situation et prendre les mesures les
plus drastiques qu'on ne doit pas me
mettre les hôpitaux une situation où
c'est ça la véritable question est ce
que les chercheurs sont en situation
c'était c'est ce qu'on a les moyens
aujourd'hui avec la crise des urgences
le manque de la deuxième étape sur
robert métier vous dire je sais bien
qu'il ya ce problème là mais il y aura
des réquisitions si c'est la nécessité
annonce déjà de lit je le sais donc un
très bon moi je sais ce qui montre qu'il
ya un problème de sous dimensionné son
service hospitalier comme on est en
train de le faire a coupé à coup
d'austérité et qu'on va peut-être le
payer là dessus mais moi je veux dire il
faut pas paniquer effectivement mais si
on veut réduire
il fallait réduire augmenter les
contrôles aux frontières interdire le
voyage avec la chine il ya énormément de
gens potentiellement contaminés en chine
il suffit qu'ils aient trois quatre cinq
personnes qui passent sous les radars et
on n'y arrive plus parce que le problème
de cette maladie c'est 80 % des gens
n'ont pas de symptômes
ils le ressentent comme un rhume et
après il ya 20% dès gens qui ont des
problèmes beaucoup plus graves mais il y
avait 80 80 % c'est rien du tout c'est
une toux etc et donc ils le savent pas
ils vont contaminer énormément de gens
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il fallait
faire contrôler les frontières avant
mais ça malheureusement
je veux dire il ya une telle idéologie
sans frontières est ce que fermer les
frontières c'est presque un drame c'est
presque un drame pour notre pays
donc parce que on a l'impression que
c'est une catastrophe
alors que c'était une mesure scène ça se
passe très bien aux états unis ils ont
fermé les frontières et clash ni sont
réglables aussi la ferme étant un peu
critiqué mais en face on a l'habitude
avec les russes et les chinois
les chinois sont pas contents avec les
états unis aient fait ça mais je veux
dire on peut les comprendre mais on est
obligé de se protéger les uns les autres
et je pense que quand un pays comme les
etats unis se protègent ils se protègent
de l'épidémie pour lui il protège les
autres pays du monde ne pas avoir
l'épidémie aux états unis et de la
transmettre ailleurs patrick mennucci
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas
peut nier des orgies sur ce côté roula
le gros mot ferme les frontières on ne
regarde l étrange donc j'avais attendu
le le métier qui a bloqué jeudi 17 6 si
vous fermez la frontière il dit c'est
très bien parce quils d'ailleurs il se
prononce pas il dit vous pouvez la
fermer c'est une mesure qui est plus
politique que sanitaire parce que vous
avez dit pas que ça uniquement de ça
réduit un petit peu de sérieux que tu
peux essayer mais le virus y passe avec
les gens là tiamat pas tous et il dit
aussi que c'est pas preneur températures
déjà parce que comme vous l'avez dit
mais pataquès deux jours la petite foire
intéressant rien alors mais est-ce qu'il
faut pas arrêter avec ça veut dire qu'il
faut liant des alliés la france pour la
lorsque les questions sais pas il n'y a
pas que du tourisme wade en mai que déjà
la région rappelle juste qu'il ya 15 ans
les noms d'établir une côté d'or c'est
hier et ils ont rejoint des niçois qui
travaille sur la riviera italienne et
sari conséquences moi je mais s'il faut
le faire il faut le faire est si fort
que j'adore c'est la question
je combats mais pape eric ciotti que je
connais très bien et je connais ce
d'engagement sur ces sujets de de
frontières extérieure c'est bien le ils
demandent pas à faire voiture les
frontières et des douanes de le
contrôler
1 parce qu'il ya les minima lui c'est
que vous posiez les causes et
départementales isolement après si
effectivement la situation
ça veut dire ça sera si vous savez si si
malheureusement il faut bien trois mille
fontanet qu'ils puissent pas aller
travailler pendant quinze jours pour
protéger ce soit pour les nôtres si vous
avez des 65 millions d'euros mais sa
sereine et ça serait une bonne chose
l'erreur de la chine on est en train de
la refaire ils ont laissé one comme ça
non confiné pendant trop longtemps et
derrière ça posait des problèmes majeurs
il faut pas la faire deux fois merci
messieurs merci et philippe muray
respecte mennucci d'avoir des battus on
se retrouve dans quelques minutes pour 1
point complet sur l'actualité
merci
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même que
veut-il dire en japonais et qui comme
henri daure il veut dire qu'ils ne
sortent pas de chez soi tout simplement
le propre du phénomène hikikomori c'est
que on trouve des jeunes au japon qui
refuse de sortir de chez eux alors
qu'eux ils n'ont pas de pathologie
identifiée dans la nomenclature
psychiatriques aujourd'hui les kicks
mort ils sont pas des fadas de jeux
vidéo c'est pas des gens qui passent
tout leur temps dans leur chambre
scotché à l'ordinateur à jouer aux jeux
vidéo et c'est un documentaire qui
permet de comprendre en quoi ce
phénomène est vraiment spécifique de la
culture japonaise au japon la pression
scolaire est extrêmement forte
mais les parents s'endettent souvent à
vie pour que leurs enfants fassent des
études et puis vous savez au moment de
la crise d'adolescence un bel quelque
chose qui est remis en question
c'est une super méga crise d'adolescence
considérablement majorait par la
situation économique culturel social
familial qui lie au japon
[Musique]
e
oui c'est comme si j'étais passé à une
autre époque les cadets un peu de nerf
c'est quoi ce chaos
je suis plus une personne de la terre ou
faux et aujourd'hui j'ai quitté la
maison pour aller en mer et c'est moi le
maître du perroquet bordel
[Musique]
regardez c'est pas croyable
ok je ne pensais pas être si forte
avant même une barque sur une rivière
genre yves peur de me noyer
mais maintenant je m'en fiche
on va pas couler avec ce bateau enfin si
dieu le veut
[Musique]
il
premier jour du procès d'extradition de
julian assange au royaume uni ils
risquent 175 année prison aux etats-unis
washington qui a accusé le fondateur de
wikileaks d'avoir mis des sources ont
mangé en publiant une masse
d'informations pacifier le monde doit se
préparer à une éventuelle pandémie de
coronavirus indique l'om est inquiet
plus de frais 150 nouveaux décès en
chine où la propagation est décliné en
moins en france il n'y a plus aucun
malade hospitalisé pour ce virus alors
qu'un sixième patient est mort en italie
11000 du nord sont passés en quarantaine
les retraites au bout de huit jours
d'examens l'assemblée adopte les
premiers des soixante cinq articles du
projet de loi de réforme
non sans suspension ni rappelle à
l'ordre les avocats à eux entament leur
septième semaine de grève ce qui a
entraîné un report à mercredi le conseil
de l'ex premier ministre françois fillon
et de son épouse dans la sphère des
sources on d'emplois fictifs
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
si vous nous rejoignez julian assange
saura-t-il extradé vers les états unis
premier jour de procès pour le fondateur
de wikileaks qui comparaît depuis ce
matin devant la justice britannique
londres doit décider de donner suite ou
non à la demande américaine de
l'extrader les précisions depuis londres
avec à notre reporter mon hamoud
il faudra attendre plusieurs semaines
pour connaître le sort du lanceur
l'alertent julian assange qui est
incarcéré à la prison juste derrière moi
la prison
un belle marche au sud de londres pour
rappel il a été il est accusé par les
états unis et d'espionnage pour avoir
révélé plusieurs documents confidentiels
concernant l'activité de l'armée
américaine en irak et en afghanistan
l'audience a d'abord débuté par l
accusation 30 minutes ont été accordés à
la défense il faut savoir que pendant
toute cette journée d'audience julian
assange n'a jamais pu prendre la parole
ne serait ce que pour se défendre il
faut également mentionner que plusieurs
rassemblements dans le monde entier
également à londres où était organisée
en soutien de julian assange des gilets
jaunes étaient présents ici des anglais
mais également des allemands et
plusieurs personnes venues d'autres pays
pour soutenir
julian assange plusieurs champs ont été
entendus comme free assange à savoir l
libérez assange
le père de julian assange est également
venu à cette audition il était
extrêmement ému par la présence
médiatique mais également par les
soutient et qui était venu ici pour
cette audience je vous propose de
l'écouter
après 10 ans d'enquêté
dix ans l'afer a été abandonné les
charges ont été abandonnées
ils étaient quatre procureurs vous avez
bien vu tout cela et il n'a fallu que
huit ans pour mettre un homme sur la
lune
dix ans
oas le dernier élément reste
l'accusation contre julian d'avoir aidé
chelsea manning une fête à son procès
celle ci a parlé de sa motivation et de
sa décision délibérée de se tourner vers
julian et wikileaks et de se mettre en
contact avec lui afin de laisser fuiter
ces documents préoccupant abordant des
injustices et des crimes de guerre in
just sa mort vous l'avez entendu le père
de julian assange qui s'est exprimé à la
fin de cette audience il a également eu
des avocats et en l'occurrence le
rédacteur en chef de wikileaks qui
estime que l'affairé assange et ags est
un cas politique il alerte également sur
l'état de santé du fondateur de
wikileaks qui ne fait que se dégrader il
a parlé de dépression mais également de
risque de suicide écoute et le morphing
bio il n'y a rien de nouveau rien que
nous n'avons pas déjà entendu en disant
cette accusation de faire du mal en
exposant le crime de guerre
le mal fait en irak en afghanistan c'est
une allégation qui ne tenait pas la
route il ya dix ans et qui ne tient
certainement pas la route aujourd'hui et
c'est une tactique de propagande pour
détourner l'attention sur le fait que
wikileaks avait exposé des crimes des
crimes de guerre graves se posent il
faudra donc patienter plusieurs semaines
avant de connaître le verdict aux etats
unis
julian assange fait face à 18 chefs
d'accusation il encourt jusqu'à 175 ans
de prison pour ai depuis son lancement
en 2006 par julian assange wikileaks a
mis en lumière de nombreux cas
d'espionnage aux deux violations des
droits humains retour en images sur les
scandales les plus retentissants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut
m
[Musique]
anthony bellanger secrétaire général de
la fédération internationale des
journalistes restent optimistes mais
espère que la justice anglaise est bien
indépendantes contenu de décharge kitty
qui sont aujourd'hui sur sur le cas de
julian assange
je reste très optimiste puisque
quelqu'un qui lierait le droit
international de façon classique on
comprendrait tout simplement qu' il n'y
a aucune charge contre lui aujourd'hui
qu'il faut quand même savoir de quoi on
parle
la part de l'intérêt général
d'information destinée au public et non
de évidemment de d'espionnage comme les
américains tentent de le démontrer
aujourd'hui j'espère en tout cas que la
justice anglaise est indépendante
ce qui n'est évidemment pas le cas de
des cours de justice qui attendrait
julian assange en virginie s'il devait
être extradé dans dans l'année où là on
est vraiment là autant dans nos sièges
réellement delà de l'année c'est
notamment donc là on sait qu'il y aura
des dépressions qui seront autres et ils
sont évidemment politique aucun cas
connus de contamination du coronavirus
en france pour l'instant le nouveau
ministre olivier ferrand s'est voulu
rassurant lors d'un point presse soient
écoutés il n'y a ce soir pas de
circulation du virus sur le territoire
national c'est important de le rappeler
car notre stratégie est fonction du
niveau de risque
elle est surtout je lisais hier soir
adaptable et révisable à tout moment
aujourd'hui tout est mis en place pour
freiner l'introduction dû virus sur le
territoire par le dépistage des cas
possibles notamment
nous avons augmenté considérablement nos
capacités diagnostic
comme je le disais par l'isolément des
malades et je vous annonce qu'il n'y a
ce soir plus aucun malade hospitalisé en
france le dernier patient qui était
hospitalisé à lyon est guéri n'est plus
contagieux il a pu rentrer chez lui et
par les enquêtes de terrain comme ce qui
a été brillamment organisé à contamines
montjoie grâce à la mobilisation de
toutes les équipes sanitaires des
agences régionales de santé les
problèmes de santé libéraux et
hospitaliers et des déclarations alors
que 150 nouveaux décès ont été
enregistrés en chine aujourd'hui le
il n'avait pas signalé au temps mort de
pie ix on joue auprès de 2600 personnes
au total ont perdu la vie depuis
décembre mais on note un déclin dans la
propagation ailleurs dans le monde la
corée du nord est désormais le plus
grand foyer de l'épidémie avec sept
morts et 763 personnes contaminées puis
vient l'iran où le virus a fait état de
12 morts en italie le virus lui a tué
une septième personne et la situation
est préoccupante dans le nord du pays
confronté à une hausse des cas de
contamination l'europe invite les états
membres à se coordonner mais à ne pas
paniquer alors que l'om est celle tire
la sonnette d'alarmé et demande au monde
de se préparer à une éventuelle pandémie
du virus france pâtissier ne pas céder à
la panique
c'est ce qu'a déclaré la commission
européenne lors d'une conférence de
presse devant l'explosion de k2
coronavirus en italie bruxelles a donc
décidé de lancer l' alerte tout en
appelant au calme et à l'unité de cette
situation je voudrais dire aujourd'hui
que nous allons faire tout notre
possible pour aider les états membres à
faire face à la situation
bien sûr prendre cette situation très au
sérieux mais nous ne devons pas céder à
la panique et plus important encore à la
désinformation
nous devons être très sûrs aidant mitre
réponse cohérente et coordonnée avec le
développement du virus sur le continent
c'est aussi la question de la libre
circulation des personnes au sein de
l'espace schengen qui est posée pour
l'instant la commission n'entend pas
faire de recommandations sur la
fermeture éventuelle des frontières
sujets qui relèvent de la prérogative
des états membres nous pensons que les
mesures doivent être en premier lieu
fondée sur une évaluation crédible des
risques et des preuves scientifiques
deuxièmement les mesures doivent être
proportionnées et troisièmement elle
doit être prise en coordination avec
d'autres nous devrions agir en tant
qu'union et non individuellement
le code des frontières schengen permet
de réintroduire temporairement les
contrôles aux frontières
mais une telle mesure comme je les dis
je dois être prise compte tenu des
conditions que je vais le mentionner
l'italie est d'ailleurs proposé une
réunion des ministres de la santé des
pays frontaliers de la péninsule ce
mardi après midi pour déterminer des
lignes d'action commune et un contrôle
aux frontières pourraient être rétablis
il faut dire que l'inquiétude gagne les
villes proches de la frontière italienne
en france la préfecture des
alpes-maritimes a annoncé ce lundi après
midi la mise en place d'une cellule de
vigilance quotidienne et le renforcement
du dispositif sanitaire des mesures de
précaution pour les personnes revenant
du nord de l'italie seront également
prises dans tout l'hexagone alors que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
demande au monde de se préparer à une
éventuelle pandémie est pour gérald
kerzec médecin urgentiste et mesures de
contrôle aux frontières où on attend un
intérêt politique davantage que
médicales on est encore dans une phase
en france on peut isoler les patients la
fenêtre de tir elle va être relativement
courte parce que on voit bien qu'en
italie ils sont à plus de 200 cas plus
on a des cas qui se multiplient plus
l'enjeu n'est plus finalement de les
isoler mais vraiment de les traiter way
vient ici on a plusieurs centaines de
patients ça va être compliqué de les
isoler on n'imagine pas pour la grippe
par exemple isolé tout le monde donc
cette mesure contrôle des frontières
voire de fermeture des frontières je
pense pas qu'en france on puisse fermer
les frontières mais elle aura un côté
symbolique qui serait peut-être pas
inutile ce contrôle de température ne
serait ce que pour rassurer les gens
mais on est bien d'accord sur le plan
médical c'est pas ça qui empêchera la
diffusion du virus ce virus il est très
contagieux on le voit en italie on sait
même pas quel est le patient 0 1 quel
est le patient source ce virus il est il
a été transporté véhiculer
2 shin et on voit bien que ça paraît
extrêmement difficile de maintenir une
situation hermétique en france avec zéro
cas sur le territoire et en france
nouvelle semaine de débats sur le projet
de réforme des retraites à l'assemblée
nationale le premier des 65 artistes
article du projet de loi a été adopté
sous les applaudissements de la majorité
entre rappels au règlement et
suspensions de séance à répétition il
aura fallu 70 heures de débat pour venir
à bout des quelques deux mille deux
cents amendements et sous amendements
déposés principalement par les
oppositions sur cet article
il a été validé par 89 voix contre 46 et
les avocats eux restent vent debout
contre cette réforme du régime autonome
des retraites
ils sont plusieurs dizaines à avoir
bloqué ce matin les entrées du tribunal
de paris les annonces la semaine
dernière de nicole belloubet n'ont pas
suffi à apaiser leur colère
la garde des sceaux a déposé un
amendement qui prévoit d'instaurer un
dispositif de solidarité des avocats
objectif faire baisser le montant des
cotisations pour ceux dont le revenu est
inférieur à 80 milles euros annuels pas
assez selon ses avocats combat entendre
comme vous le savez les avocats sont
mobilisés à tout le moins depuis le 6
janvier par une grève dure et générale
de tous les barreaux de france contre le
projet de réforme des retraites nous
faisons renvoyer tous les dossiers nous
ne désignons plus les avocats à l'aide
juridictionnelle et maintenant nous
allons passer à l'étape supérieure
c'est-à-dire bloqué l'entrée des
juridictions ce sont nos juridictions
c'est là où on travaille tous les jours
et donc pour essayer de nous faire
entendre puisque même des loubet et le
gouvernement de monsieur macro ne nous
entendent pas eh bien nous passons à la
vitesse supérieure nous avons appris que
le parlement envisage de faire voter la
réforme des retraites avec le 49-3 eh
bien nous nous sortons notre 49,3 qui
consiste à bloquer le pallec justice
parce que nous sommes dans une situation
de blocage absolu les 70000 avocats de
france sont en grève
croyez-moi si les 70000 avocats de
france sont en grève ce n'est pas pour
le plaisir c'est parce que notre
profession notre métier risque de
disparaître en tout cas à tiers des
avocats de france risquent de
disparaître avec l'augmentation de la
cotisation qui est prévu dans la réforme
des retraites n'auront pas entendu cette
besson
sue par la chancellerie qui dit toujours
la même chose c'est à dire des âneries
qui nous propose des choses qui sont
parfaitement inacceptables qui nous
demande de financer en réalité le
passage au système universel ce qui est
inacceptable
on peut pas demander un avocat de voir
ses cotisations doublée
c'est pension baisser sans qu'ils
fassent rien et je crains que le
gouvernement n'ait pas bien compris qu
on lâchera rien même s'ils font une
carence ils font passer de 49,3 et leila
al-zawi avocate président d'honneur de
l'union des jeunes avocats de paris
fustige la fin de non recevoir du
gouvernement
mon explication personnelle c'est que
c'est que de la com derrière la garde
des sceaux elle n'a rien n'à offrir et
ce sont que des éléments de langage des
petites saillies des agressions des
dénigrements où on nous infantilise mais
en réalité derrière ça il n'y a aucun
moyen sur un projet qui est mal rédigée
mal préparé et complètement impossible à
contrôler pour nous on sait lire un
texte où tout ne présente un abondement
une proposition qui n'en est pas une
on sait dire que c'est que c'est que
c'est un abus et c'est ça je pense la
différence essentielle et c'est pour ça
qu effectivement il ya un mépris
grandissant parce qu'au lieu de répondre
à sa part une réflexion profonde sur les
alertes qu'on fait la réaction c'est ce
que je vous disais c'est nous
infantiliser nous mépriser et c'est vrai
qu'on le vit particulièrement mal il
n'ya pas d'étude d'impact un réellement
du gouvernement ils ont fourni des
chiffres des exemples types qui était
pas du tout réaliste qui était pas ce
qu'on avait demandé et l'étude d'impact
est complètement vide
en revanche chez nous on a une chambre
qui nous a fait une simulation
effectivement d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement leur a intimé de retirer
tellement ça les arrange et pas et les
résultats sont catastrophiques c'est à
dire que ça ça remontrer à la profession
combien la situation était
catastrophique et convient ça n'avait
absolument pas été anticipée est une
conséquence de cette contestation des
avocats le très attendu procès fillon
qui devait débuter aujourd'hui a été
renvoyée à mercredi
l'ancien premier ministre et son épouse
ainsi que marc joulaud ancien suppléant
de françois fillon à l'assemblée
nationale vont comparaître dans la
sphère des emplois présumés fictifs de
pénélope fillon les précisions de notre
reporter katia technique
le procès de l'ancien premier ministre
soit fillon a été renvoyé au 26 février
à 13h30 et trois avocats des prévenus
avaient demandé un renvoi en solidarité
à la grève des avocats contre la réforme
des retraites
lors de l'audience à 13h30 m antonin
lévy la défense de françois fillon a dit
vouloir exprimer sa sympathie envers ses
confrères donc renvoie les trois
prévenus sont sortis de la salle
d'audience sans faire de déclaration
marc joulaud et françois fillon étaient
poursuivis pour détournement de fonds
publics
pénélope fillon pour recel et complicité
et en outre le couple fillon sera
poursuivi pour complicité et recel
d'abus de biens sociaux
en effet pénélope fillon est accusé
d'avoir perçu plus d'un million d'euros
de fonds publics entre 1998 et 2000 13
en étant assistante parlementaire un
emploi possiblement fictifs alors pour
cela les trois prévenus encourent
jusqu'à dix ans de prison et de fortes
amendes et une peine d'inéligibilité
nous avons interviewé m if claisse qui
est l'avocat de l'assemblée nationale et
qui évoque la question du remboursement
mais ce n'est pas une première pour
l'assemblée nationale que de demander le
remboursement de rémunération qui serait
considérée par la justice
encore une fois son mandat n'a pas de
pouvoir de police c'est l'application
d'une doctrine traditionnelle qui
s'applique
et de façon constante le canard enchaîné
avait dévoilé en janvier 2017 ces
soupçons d'emplois fictifs
ainsi de nombreux autres révélations
mais françois fillon n'avait pas
abandonné la course à la présidentielle
pour autant et ce malgré une mise en
examen
alors la sanction des urnes a été rude
puisque françois fillon n'a obtenu que
20 de 0 1% des suffrages au premier tour
il a donc été éliminé c'était la
première fois que la droite ne passait
pas le second tour lors de la cinquième
république et aujourd'hui ce procès
était très attendue par les citoyens il
y avait plus d'une centaine de
journalistes devant cette salle
d'audience c'est un procès qui est
également très attendue par la droite
qui a envie de tourner la page de la
sphère fillon qui avait sérieusement
entaché sa réputation salon de
l'agriculture a ouvert ses portes samedi
l'occasion de mettre en lumière le
malaise généralisé du monde agricole
selon les chiffres un agriculteur se
suicident tous les deux jours en france
le gouvernement a d'ailleurs confié au
député de lot-et-garonne olivier des
baisers une mission pour la prévention
du futile agricole un sujet signé betsen
chebbi avec rania berrada et julien de
la cour vous avez bien le sujet a été
abordé par emmanuel macron lors de
l'inauguration du salon de l'agriculture
parce que j'ai trouvé
petit bâtiment
il manque d'un revenu perspectives et
bien entendu la culpabilisation
selon les chiffres les plus récents de
la msa la sécurité sociale des
agriculteurs
il y a eu six en cinq suicides de
paysans au cours de l'année 2015 contre
150 car moyenne entre 2007 et 2011
un nombre en hausse qui traduit un
malaise croissant dans le monde agricole
ça s'explique par l'augmentation des
charges et pays nos produits qui sont
pas en cohérence qui soit incohérent par
rapport à nos charges voilà donc je
trouve que le mal il s'est fait surtout
depuis l'euro on a des charges qui sont
rendus qu'on payait en francs
aujourd'hui on les paye en euros alors
que nos produits ont prévalu et de 6
ennemis pas par l'argent enfin lunaire
entre le le franc et l'euro tpiy boss et
plus en plus dures faut des structures
qui sont plus en plus grosse
on est loin de moins en moins de monde à
travailler dessus et puis bah c'est des
charges qui augmentent et puis comme le
produit pour rémunérer en fonction de ça
je me répète mais ben voilà ça se
comprend notre boulot principal ce
serait de nourrir la population est
aujourd'hui la population nous tirent
dessus à boulet rouge à cause de la
grille bashing donc on nous prend pour
des produits empoisonneurs pour des on a
sans arrêt des problèmes pour la
maltraitance animale et toutes ces
choses là donc on comprend ce répit que
consorts qu'on sente qu'on soit
réellement soutenu par le consommateur
aujourd'hui
on vient à paris c'est pour informer le
consommateur il parlait comme on
travaille mais on a le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui le salon à paris c'est
plus le zoo du parisien qu'autre chose
un malaise que semble avoir entendu
emmanuel macron le président français a
annoncé avoir confié à olivier damaisin
député de lot-et-garonne une mission
pour améliorer la prévention du suicide
agricole il devra rendre un rapport dans
les six prochains mois au premier
ministre et au ministre de l'agriculture
et de la santé et pour périco légasse
journaliste et critique gastronomique le
fait que le gouvernement demande un
rapport sur le mal être des agriculteurs
est une réponse scénique
on sait très bien qu'une mission
parlementaire arrête tout de suite du
suicide et que ceux qui étaient venus de
misère et dans la détresse dans une
charrette et non une fois de plus de
gouvernement se moque se moque du monde
et là on donne une une sensation un peu
de un peu de mépris parce que la
situation est vraiment grave on à ce
salon de l'agriculture qui est le salon
de l'industrie agricole et la grande
distribution ou la partie paysanne n'est
qu'une devanture folklorique pour amuser
les visiteurs puisque comme les espoirs
ce pinceau et on a tous les responsables
de la détresse agricole française les
grandes firent les multinationales les
semenciers le syndicat majoritaire qui
depuis 40 ans cogère l'agriculture
française et le gouvernement et a envoyé
la culture française dans le mur et là
c'est une un acte de cynisme les
différents gouvernements qui se
succèdent en france avec cette crise
agricole cette détresse agricole
c'est un cynisme et un mépris sans
comparaison
des tapis rouge pour donald trump
pendant le président américain est
arrivé ce matin pour une visite d'état
de deux jours au programme un meeting
géant côté du premier ministre indien
dans un drame au dit donald trump
s'envolera ensuite vers new delhi
les deux pays sont engagés dans un bras
de fer commercial depuis l'année
dernière et deux hommes ont affiché à
l'avancé de leurs relations avec de
futurs accords commerciaux
nous sommes aux première étape des
discussions en vue d'un incroyable
accord commercial visant à réduire les
barrières des investissements entre les
etats-unis et l'un et je suis heureux
d'annoncer que demain nos représentants
signeront un accord pour la vente de
plus de 3 milliards de dollars
d'hélicoptères militaires et d'autres
équipements à la pointe de la
technologie aux forces armées indiennes
je me souviens lorsque je suis allé à
washington la première fois que j'ai
rencontré le président trump il m'avait
dit que l'inde avait un véritable ami à
la maison blanche le président trump a
toujours montré son amour particulier
pour l'inde
que ce soit dans les secteurs de la
défense de l'énergie de la santé ou des
technologies de l'information dans tous
les secteurs
nos relations se renforce et pour claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales en s'alliant avec l'inde
les états unis souhaite contenir
l'influencé chinoise croissance pour les
états unis l'inde est un enjeu
fondamental puisque l'inde est la clé de
la stratégie ados pacifique des états
unis c'est à dire d'une stratégie qui va
de l'océan indien à l'océan pacifique
et évidemment l'inde occupe la position
clé il s'agit en fait de contenir
l'influencé chinoise croissante dans
toute l'asie pacifique dans toute cette
zone est pour cela est évidemment le
pays qui de l'autre côté de l'himalaya
peut faire progressivement équilibre à
la chine alors il ya aussi naturellement
le fait que l'inde est devenue la
cinquième économie du monde
ce qui est tout à fait considérable elle
a dépensé l'année dernière la france et
la grande bretagne
elle est encore assez loin mais pas
tellement de l'allemagne plus loin du
japon
naturellement très loin de la chine et
les états unis mais enfin la cinquième
puissance économique ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'elle a sur ces voies
d'approvisionnement qu'elles assurent sa
sécurité qu'elle constitue des forces
navales des forces de défense le jihad
islamique palestinien vient d'annoncer
qu'il poursuivrait les frappes contre
israël alors que se sont tenues les
funérailles aujourd'hui en syrie pour la
mort de deux combattants du jihad
islamique tués dans la nuit par des
frappes israéliennes le groupe affirme
vouloir poursuivre ses attaques en
raison de la continuité des frappes de
l'état hébreu les roquettes qui ont visé
plusieurs zones de la bande de gaza
aujourd'hui provoquant une escalade des
tensions des deux côtés hier nous avons
attaqué plusieurs zones
nous avons attaqué en syrie nous avons
attaqué à gaza et nous continuons de
frapper en ce moment avec des avions des
chars et nous continuerons de frapper
jusqu'au retour au calme
j'ai aussi un message pour les
dirigeants des organisations terroristes
si le calme ne revient pas vous êtes les
prochains dans la ligne de mire
l'acte de la résistance et unis et
répondra soit depuis la bande de gaza
soit en confrontant ces attaques en
syrie et cette réponse continuera nous
considérons que l'arrogance sioniste ne
durera pas la patience de la kz2 la
résistance a ses limites
j'adore de france il y en a des masses
ne sont pas surprenantes
cette annonce d'abord pour la syrie on a
eu je crois
plusieurs centaines quelques années 2011
on parle de 200 250 on ne sait pas
exactement est ce que les sentiments
parquet y aura peut-être une escalade à
gaza mais on ne voit pas ce qu'ils
peuvent escaladé en plus
disons les lignes au djihad islamique et
les mouvements résistance palestinienne
riposte désormais et envoie des missiles
des engins sur israël je pense que c'est
le cas des éléments de la nouveauté
quand même libre des forces a changé
dans la région et c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité demain
matin 7 heures du matin heure française
excellente fin de soirée tous eu une
réponse
[Musique]
est ce que la chine et la nouvelle
superpuissance du sport tout est
réalisable à la mesure de l'ambition
dévorante de la chine
je pense que dans les années à venir ça
va être un rival important pour être
pour dominer le sport mondial
l'ambition que ce que s'est donnée le
président jean ping s'est non seulement
d'avoir le plus grand nombre de
médailles mais d'avoir le plus grand
nombre